be a leader in my community,
allow myself along with other
minorities to wear culturally
significant items during their
graduation ceremony. This not
only commemorates their hard
work but allows them to be
representatives of their
culture to their culture. In
closing, I would like to leave
you with this quote. Be the
change you wish see. If you
want, if you want this to, if
you want this change so badly,
you will please kindly consider
this policy change. Thank you,
mister Robinson.
Go ahead. For the record, my
name is Ashley Garcia
Valledares. Good evening. My
Valledares and I am currently a
senior in Rancho High School
and I am the president of
Speech and Debate. We're at a
time where I'm about to
graduate and I've accomplished
many things throughout the
school year and I'm proud of
how far I've progressed. I want
to not only show what I've
accomplished through my
hard-earned courts, medals, and
high school diploma but I also
want to celebrate my identity.
The motion I want to bring into
discussion today concerns
graduating students and the
dress code. Quote unquote,
jewels or decorations on caps
or gowns. Nolays, stalls,
cords, or medals other than
those issued by your respective
CCSD high school. I find this
rule to violate upon my rights
as a student and a citizen in
the United States. Known as
declared in a Supreme Court
case known as Tinker V Des
Moines, students were able to
express their form of symbolic
speech as long as it does not
cause an undue disruption.
Being able to wear a Mexican
Guatemalan flag along with my
hard-earned medals, courts, and
high school di is how I express
my symbolic speech. I want to
have the ability to celebrate
the fact that as a young
Hispanic and first generation
woman that I was able to
graduate during a pandemic.
That's a huge accomplishment.
Not everyone in this room can
say that they endured they
endured a year in high school
online. Now and they also
endured other chaos around that
whole year. That's again a huge
accomplishment. And I want to
display that. We can easily
include diversity and allow
students to represent
individuality and not at the
expense of maintaining decorum.
I propose that the cultural,
heritage, and identity-based
graduation items be approved
upon to give students like me
and those who signed our
petition the opportunity to
celebrate our identities, to
honor, to honor our families,
and our communities. I want to
show that any student is
capable of achieving their
diplomas regardless of
ethnicity, religion, gender,
sexual orientation, or income
status. Thank you. Thank you,
miss Percy Valdez.
Welcome. Hi, for the record, my
name is Jacob Drum. Okay. Uh
so, when do I begin? Okay. Uh
my name is Jacob Drum and I'm a
senior Green Valley High
School. Uh one thing I sorry.
My name is Jacob Drummond. I'm
a senior at Green Valley High
School. One thing I believe in
is rationality and another
thing I believe in is
education. And I believe that
we should create incentive
structures so that a rational
student would want to perceive
an a good education. Now, of
course, not all students are
rational and really no student
is but at the very least, our
incentive structures should
incentivize students to go to
class and a rational student
should want to go to class from
the incentive structure.
However, this in contradiction
with the Green Valley attorney
policy and with a lot of tardy
policies that exist right now.
If you go to school and I'm
five minutes late, what am I
going to do? Am I going to go
to class or am I going to sit
in my car? Well, I'm going to
tell you right now. I'm
going to sit in my car and get
that absence excused and I'll
tell you why. Because on the
first, first absence and the
second, sorry, on the first and
second target, you get a
detention and apparent
notification. Now, if you are a
rational student and you are
five minutes late to class
because perhaps something
happened on the way to school.
Perhaps, you know, something
happened at home. What are you
going to do going to go to
class or are you going to sit
in your car? You're going to
sit in your car and throughout
the many conversations I've had
with fellow students, they all
agree on this. I've gotten text
messages from my friends many
times saying, hey, I'm not in
class or I would ask him, why
aren't you in class? And they
would say, well, do I want an
attention or would I rather
just get my absence excuse for
literally no penalty? For this
reason, I believe it is
imperative that we change the
target policy structures that
we incentivize students to go
to class. like to note, it
might be tempting to say, why
don't we punish them harder for
being absent? Uh I don't think
punishment is the right
solution here. I think we
should make students want to go
believ
e that, you know, we
should create a stuck structure
in which a rational human being
would want to pursue an
education rather than not go to
class as it is right now. So,
that's it and thank you very
much. Thank you, Mr. Drum.
Please, thank you for
completing your yellow form,
mister Drum. Jacob, if you
could please give us your
yellow form if it's completed.
Thank you so much. Are there
any other students in the
audience who would like to
address a public comment on our
agenda items? Nope. At this
time, I'd like to congratulate
the seniors who are in the
room. Thank you for your hard
work.
We are very proud of you.
Moving on, the first person in
public comment is Jenna
Robertson. After Jenna, we've
got Vicky Cardel and Autumn
Tampa. Welcome.
Thank you. My name is Jenna
Robertson. I'm a mom of five
CCSD students and I had planned
to come here tonight to talk
about how complicated the new
COSA process is, how difficult
it is to navigate, especially
online, and how frustrating to
have no appeals process. Our
family bought a new home after
the COSA deadline and while no
kid likes change or wants to
leave their friends, one of my
children was in significant
distress over changing schools.
She had gotten some incorrect
information from a teacher
about simply applying for his
own variants and when I told
her the process was different
this year and her school didn't
have openings and there was
nothing I could do. She was
convinced I just wasn't
advocating for her enough. Um
she was angry and then she was
distraught and based on the
information on the CCSD
website. Miss, excuse me,
ladies and gentlemen, please do
not engage with the audience.
Excuse miss Robinson, we will
pause your time. Thank you. At
this time, I'd like Miss
Robertson to get Jenna. Hi,
Jenna. Thank you so much for
your patience. You're welcome
too. Okay. Continue. Okay. My
daughter was angry and then she
was distraught about changing
schools and based on the
information on the CCSD
website, I felt hopeless. After
my first no, I wrote my trustee
to express my frustration and
ask if there truly was nothing
to be done. I received an email
from the COSA assistant again
telling me no, sorry. So, just
when I was planning to come
here and say the student mental
health has to be more than a
buzzword at a press conference
for this district, I learned
that my trustee took a
student's request and her
mental health seriously. She
got my email to the
superintendent and to Joe
Caruso who got my plea to the
right department. Then, I got a
third corre from the Kosa
department where we learned we
did in fact qualify for an
administrative something
something and my daughter would
get to stay at her current
school. You have never seen a
more relieved kid or a more
relieved mom. Trustee Guzman.
Thank you sincerely for hearing
my kid. Thank you for taking
her mental health seriously. It
was really an issue in our
home. It is no longer an issue
in our home. Thank you. Um
Superintendent Jara. Thank you
for your staff that
communicated so clearly with me
during this whole process.
Online not clear at all. Once I
got somebody on the phone,
fantastic. Thank you. Um I
especially thank Joe Caruso and
I want to thank Gia Moore with
the Kosa department who spent
time on the phone with me
yesterday thinking that I was
still upset. I was not. I'm
almost done. Please. I was
interrupted. Please. Um I
want to thank you. I want to
thank you all. on behalf of my
daughter, who knows that her
mom tried her best and who
knows that I reached out to you
on this board and she knows
that you tried your best for
her too. It worked out for us.
Thank you. That's all. Thank
you, Jenna. Miss Robertson.
Miss Cardel
Thank you for finding your way
out of our boardroom.
Appreciate it. Go ahead Miss
Cordell.
Good evening My name is Vicki
Cardell. I'm a CCSD teacher and
president of NEA of Southern
Nevada. School board meetings
are business meetings. We're
here because we want our
district to work. We want the
kids to feel safe and
successful. Also encourage
educators to tell you they're
bored when something isn't
right. But here and all over
the US, school boards are under
attack. The attacks are done by
groups of parent advocates with
similar sounding names. The
focus changes from masks to
CRT, Bennett pivots to
education, etcetera. Although
these people say they're trying
to protect their kids from
indoctrination, their agenda is
really to cause division and
damage public school districts.
These people have taken what
were quiet business meetings
most of the time and changed
them into occasional screaming
matches. Educators are being
called names, accused of all
sorts of things from
suffocating kids with masks to
being groomers. We're being
slandered here and liabled on
social media. But make no
mistake In all these meetings,
the goal is to disrupt school
business and to silence
educators. These actions are
strategic, well-funded, and
coordinated. Just listen to
board meetings from Tennessee
to California and you'll hear
the same themes over and over.
They're meant to I learned a
lot about what's going on from
NEA. And President Becky
Pringle says at a time when our
students need us most, and when
parents and educators have been
working together in partnership
to do everything we can to
support our students. It
unconscionable that this
orchestrated disinformation
campaign has resulted in
educators and school board
members being targeted,
threatened, and harassed. You
see, all of this is distracting
us from truly helping our
students. They need our
undivided attention as we
recover from this pandemic. We
need to prioritize school
safety and teacher retention
urgently. We must stand up
against these attacks on our
public schools and see it for
what it is a distraction for
what's really important. Thank
you, miss Cordell. Miss Tampa?
Autumn Tampa? Welcome. I'm
still being careful. Um Yeah.
Wait for Lisa to get ready.
Autumn Tampa speaking as an
individual. Firstly, I would
like to congratulate and
applaud the students who were
here and spoke tonight and all
the graduating class of twenty
twenty-two. Um I have really
been torn about all that I have
been seeing over the past
several years in this country.
And the impact that dissenting
opinions and social discontent
are having on the education of
our children. I believe that a
school should teach academics
with wraparound services for
students in need. Teachers and
education support professionals
should not have to be parents
or psychiatrists or social
workers. It often times have
had to be because children's
needs are not being met. These
are societal issues that our
state government needs to
provide for. All year, most
CCSD employees have had added
workloads. We have had COVID
safety protocols to implement
and follow. We have had to be
nurses, doctors, and
counselors. We have had
challenges with student
behavior and student loss. Over
the past year, I have had some
the some of the same
realizations that I've had time
and time again. the most
damaging and critical issues
being that there still is the
Downton Abbey effect in CCSD.
That is a perspective by
administrators, not all, but
some, that education support
professionals and often
teachers are servants, not
employees with feelings and
hopes and dreams and lives of
their own. We are supposed to
do, as we are told, without
question, and to go along with
any and everything we are told,
even if these requests are
unreasonable. We are not
respected. We are ignored and
constantly being asked to do
more and still more without
fair compensation. This is
probably one of the most
important reasons why CCSD
employees are leaving in
droves. And that there are over
2000 employee vacancies at CCSD
right now. There is much that
needs to be done. Actions speak
louder than words. Thank you.
Thank you, miss Tampa. Ladies
and gentlemen, I'm just
going to ask you to please
refrain from clapping in the
audience. I really appreciate
this so we can get through more
individuals. Mister Jose Rivera
is next along with Kathia
Sotello and I just want to
point out that we are will be
at 526 by the time that they're
done and I'd like to ask my
colleagues whether they would
like an extra 10 minutes of
public comment. Okay. Perfect.
Thank you. Welcome. Good
afternoon. My name is Jose
Rivera. I am a former student
of the CCSD School District a
current environmental justice
organizer for Make the Road
Nevada. I am speaking today to
urge the Trustees to provide
water bottle refilling stations
for all schools in the
district. We obviously live in
a desert where children are
exposed to extreme heat
temperatures during the summer
causing dehydration and
irritation which can then lead
to health concerns. water
bottle filling stations can
encourage children to hydrate
not only this but these
stations can filter out
aesthetic chlorine, taste,
odor, and lead from the water
our children drink at school. I
am aware that schools are
already equipped with drinking
fountains but this is
unsanitary especially in a
pandemic. It would be more
sanitary to provide these water
bottle filling stations as the
fountain's bubbler head would
not be touched by a child's
mouth and instead water will
pour straight into students
reusable water bottle. Water
bottle filling stations in
schools will not only ensure a
positive outcome in a student's
health but also lead us to more
eco-friendly solutions within
our district. Thank you. Thank
you so much Jose. Mister
Rivera. Katya. Is Kathia here?
How about Andy Romero? Audrey
Purr.
Jacob Parker.
Abraham Lugel Welcome, Abraham.
Go ahead. Hello, everyone. I'm
Abraham Lugo, last name LUGO
for the record. Good evening.
Thank you for being here today
and for your active listening
to our comments. I'm here as a
former student of CCSD, a now
UNLV alumni, and the economic
justice organizer for Make the
Road, Nevada. In my time with
Make the Road, my
responsibility has been to meet
the community where they're at
and listen. I've interacted
with countless of working
parents struggling in their
financial stability at a time
where we're barely coming out
of a pandemic. Striking the
high inflation affects the cost
of everyday living and wages
that are unreflective for the
needs of revival of a working
individual, let alone any
children they may need to
provide for. Statistically,
communities of color
disproportionately affected at
the forefront of such
struggles. Their children being
no exception to such a reality.
As a personal testament to
someone who has faced heavy
tolls as a result of being a
witness to my family's
financial stresses, I cannot
emphasize enough the pivotal
nature of ensuring that mental
health professionals are placed
within our schools. Where CCSD
may not able to fix every
child's home life, they can
ensure that teachers are not
the ones picking up the pieces
in everyone of their dozens of
student lives but that trained
professionals are readily
available to guide, support,
and possibly change the course
of a student's life for the
better at such troubling times.
As we're all well aware, our
state is one of the last in the
nation for education. So,
changes must be made. Fiscal
changes that prioritize our
students, their experience at
school, and a safe space to
alleviate their experience at
home as well. Let us work
together rather than on
separate playing fields to
create an equitable funding
formula that sets the
foundation for this crucial
change. I offer myself, the
voice of every student, and
every youth leader that has
come out today to help you on
this task. Our youth deserve to
thrive, not just survive
because we all do. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Mister Lugo.
Thank you, ladies and
gentlemen, for refraining from
clapping, Kendra Evans, Diana
Baptista, Baptista? Welcome.
Hello,
my name is Kendra Evans.
I'm I'm going to read you an
assignment given to my
Miss Kendra. Is everything
okay? Yeah. Okay. Go ahead.
Yeah. Miss Kendra. She's
going to read it for me. I oh.
Yes. Uh that's fine. Nope.
Forgive me. That's not fine.
Sorry.
So, yes. Okay. okay. Thank you.
I'm going to read you an
assignment given to my
15-year-old daughter at a local
high school. This will be
horrifying for me to read to
you. But that will give you
perspective on how she must
have felt when her teacher
required her to memorize this
and to act it out in front of
her entire class. I don't love
you. It's not you. It's just I
don't like your dick. Or any
dick in that case. I cheated
Joe.
I'm sorry. This is propaganda.
Forgive me. Give me. Excuse me.
I I don't. Thank you so much
for your thank you for your
comment. Forgive me. I we're
not using profanity. Are you
that's relevant? Okay. The
teachers required my daughter
to read memorize this and read
this pornographic material.
Excuse me. Please don't engage
with the audience. Okay. Yeah.
So please continue your public
comment. Your your time is
you've got one and 19 seconds.
Um I ask you simply this is a
public meeting. I asked for
decorum and I'm asking Doctor
Jara. Thank you so much Doctor
Jara.
If you don't want me to read it
to you, what was that like for
my fifteen-year-old daughter to
have to memorize pornographic
material and and memorize it
and
Madam President, members of the
board of staffs on this. Um we
can have the region
superintendent speak to her.
Thank you so much, Doctor Jara.
It seems like you may have some
concerns and while we're not
allowed to engage back and
forth in a dialogue, we would
absolutely like to make sure
that your concerns are
addressed. Material just
finished what I was going to
say. Please. My daughter was
forced to engage in the
portrayal of this blank
activity by her teacher. We
have pornography, laws
regarding minors in this state
and many of those were violated
because of this assignment. I
don't have time to to name all
of the laws that were broken
that day. but one example, NRS
200 seven one oh. It states, it
is a crime when a person
knowingly uses, encourages,
entices, or permits a minor. To
be the subject of a sexual
portrayal and a performance. In
one of my meetings with school
administration, they blame my
daughter for not saying no to
the assignment. They blamed my
daughter who is the victim.
Teachers are in a position of
power. Educators must
understand the laws about
sexual abuse. And that is where
I am hoping you will help. If I
had not reached out to a local
parent advocacy group Power to
Parent for help I may never
have gotten a meeting with the
regional superintendent. And
truly Phil this incident would
have been brushed under the
rug. However this meeting went
really well and I now have some
hope that corrective action
will happen. My daughter thinks
the world is a teacher. And I
and has about her so it's not
that I want her to get fired.
That would devastate my
daughter. I don't want to make
a horrible situation worse. But
she is struggling with this. I
hope that you will reach out to
me to let me know how you can
help. Thank you. Thank you, Ms.
Evans for taking time to come
to the board meeting. Miss
Bautista. And then after Miss
Bautista, we have Jennifer
Kilikiny. Welcome. She loves my
scarf. I love it too. It's not
mine but I borrowed it. So,
Diana Batista for the record.
So, I do want to talk about a
lot of just the mental health
issues that we kind of talked
about when the shutdown
happens. A lot of our kids when
they were isolated at home,
they really saw an impact and
so we I think we're all kind of
acknowledging that. My concern
is is once many of our kids
went back to school and it was
prior to the pandemic, many of
our kids were still sitting
alone. So, whether that was in
the lunchroom or secluded in
the classroom or whatever it
might be. Um my kids
Fortunately, have, have been
the kids that are sitting alone
at lunch. Thankfully, my son,
when he went back to school, my
youngest little guy, when he
went back to school in March,
he had kind of noticed and it
surprises me sometimes, I think
that our staff don't always
notice but he had walked into
the lunch room and he had seen
another student that was
sitting at the allergy table
and he understood that she had
or the child had allergy
issues. Um he does too. So, he
understands it and he respects
that but he had asked, you
know, mom, can you make me a
gluten free something without
peanut butter so that I can sit
with this child. This child is
sitting alone on a daily basis
and so we went and he did that.
He's been doing that since he
came out to school and I'm so
proud of him but I just I I
kind of wonder how many of us
as Trustees, staff, the school
board, how many of us have gone
into the schools post-pandemic
and gone into lunch rooms and
seed or seen how many kids are
sitting alone on a daily basis?
And I just, the reason why I
bring it to your attention is I
understand that you can't take
action on an agenda but you can
under operations and so mister
Jar F, you know, I'm going to
accountable. But I would love
if we can get some sort of
volunteer program moving
forward for many of our kids.
So that when they are in the
lunchroom or they are anywhere.
If they're sitting alone and we
have children that are willing
to sit with them. Whether they
have food allergies, they have
autism, anything that kind of
impacts the socialization. We
really take that into
consideration and just do
something moving forward that's
really positive for our kids.
So we know that there's been an
impact with behavior and I
think that that would really
help and support it. So I just
wanted to recommend that. Thank
you. Thank you Miss Bautista.
Appreciate comment Jennifer
Kilikiny. Jennifer present, not
president? Mister Gonzales, Ed
Gonzales? and after Ed, we have
room for maybe two more
individuals. Um Miss Comro and
Chuck Summers. Chuck Summers.
Yes. Thank you madam vice chair
members of the board. Uh
superintendent Jar. Um normally
I come in here and you hear who
I represent today. I'm going to
I would wear too many hats. I'm
just going to speak as an
individual. Um first of all I
do appreciate I've seen almost
half of the trustees this week.
Um I've been putting on working
with some forms actually here
where the visions are. So I do
appreciate everybody coming. Um
and then superintendent I do
appreciate the updates that
you've given us about the
health clinic over at Bailey
Middle School. I know you spoke
to our chair after Nevada talks
about and so we have not come
back to you with some
information. We have but we
will be in contact. So, we do
appreciate you following up
onto that. Um but the reason
I'm actually here today was
more about some of the comments
that was made by district staff
at a workshop at the Department
of Education at AB four
sixty-nine. I think the thing
that I find troubling is I know
this board has talked about
trying to work with the state
board. We've heard that from
many members but the language I
was used from the district was
saying and I'm going to use a
word defamatory about saying
that this district isn't
following the law. To me, that
doesn't look like trying to
work together with people. It
is, I'm going to say it's
rather shocking. you know, it's
been six years, next month the
law was passed or 7 years, six
months in October when the
regulations were passed but the
idea that the reason the state
board is taking such strong
action is because movement
hasn't been happening this long
and it started with the
previous superintendent. It
started with the previous
board. This item was passed
before and if you guys sat on
this committee, maybe Lola
Brooks was the exception when
they were going through that
process. But for the most part,
when they talk about doing
harsh languages, they want
movement from the district. And
when I heard things going,
well, we're not really
enforcing the law or they're
being misrepresented. The law
hasn't been implemented. And
so, people trying to figure out
how to get that to happen. I'm
not going to make a big deal
about it. I'm not going to sit
here and throw a hat. You know,
I'm trying to have civil
conversations. I think for the
last week, we have proven. We
can have community events, talk
about education where people
are not shouting, yelling at
each other because that's what
we need. We need to have common
sense conversations and
something where people can talk
about it so we can actually get
stuff done. So, thank you,
Madam Vice President. I
appreciate the time. Thank you,
Ed. Thank you, mister Gonzales.
I'm Miss Conroe. And And after
Miss Conroe, we have mister
Chuck Summers.
Sarah Commer for the record.
These students are our future.
Yet when they speak, it often
falls on deaf ears. And why?
Because they're young, because
they don't have 30 years of
experience, because it has
always been done one way. Well,
guess what? Youth bring fresh
ideas. The experiences and
accomplishments of this
generation are amazing. And
maybe the way it is always been
done is the wrong way. I did
not plan to come on speak here
on this tonight, but my student
Marisol, who spoke earlier,
asked for my support, and I am
here to give it wholeheartedly.
She here with a request but
also with a growth mindset and
a look towards solutions for
any possible concern that may
cause you to deny the class of
twenty twenty-two and all
classes going forward the
ability to wear cultural,
heritage, and identity-based
graduation items. We spent 12
years telling them to be their
own person, to look into
themselves, and be the best of
them that they can be. And then
at the end, we tell them to
shove everything we've been
hitting them over the head with
down, fall in line, and and
fall in line. I'm proud to call
Marisol my student and I truly
hope that you very quickly
because graduation is
approaching, find a way to let
Marisol show what she is proud
of as she walks across that
stage on June 1st. Thank you.
Thank you, miss Conroe. Thank
you for refraining from. Thank
you, audience. We're reading
from clapping. Mister Chuck?
Welcome.
Good evening, board. And I
appreciate this time to speak
my peace. I worked for the
district for 35 years. My wife
has been teaching for 50 years
in Southern Nevada. My family
has been supportive of the
district in every way. The one
thing that I find troubling
these days is a matter of trust
and respect.
as an employee I waited until
my 34th year to list any
concerns with the
superintendent. And the
response I got was a very short
hang in there.
Before
I retired, I left a
letter to the superintendent
concerned. Uh with my concerns
for how maintenance was being
run and how the employees were
being for lack of a better
word, abused as people, and
disrespected and not trusted
for what they do. I got no
response I wrote a letter to
this board with the same
concerns. Again, I got no
response.
Now while the district has been
good to me for 35 years, I was
overwhelmed by the fact that
people just don't trust or
respect and I've seen it happen
with this board. And we wonder
why our children are having a
rough time in school. We wonder
why our employees are leaving
the district in bus loads. It's
because every level of our
establishment is not doing or
living up to the trust and to
the respect that we have asked
of them. Thank you. Thank you
for your time. At this time,
ladies and gentlemen, we'd like
to move on.
We moving on to the cassette
agenda. We have some public
comment on consent. Start from
the top. The first with the
individuals who registered in
advance. Um we have Jamie Uh
Jamie, I see you on.
Perfect. After Jamie, I have
miss Bautista.
after Miss Bautista, I have
Adam Tampa. Welcome.
Okay. Um Jamie Tedrinsky for
the record. Um I wrote about
half of my comments in advance.
So, we all might be surprised
tonight. Um so, last meeting
was a little bit of a doozy
which is why I signed up for 3.
01 minutes from the last
agenda. Um because I want to
comment specifically on the
meeting from two weeks ago. Um
we made national news again.
And again, it was for the wrong
reasons. Um but when you have a
you don't have kids in the
district screaming insanity at
our board meetings. It's bound
to make its way onto Reddit,
another social media platforms.
Um so, let's get an education
tonight because I'm going to
share some definitions with the
crowd. Um libel, it's a
published false statement that
is damaging to a person's
reputation. Uh slander. It's an
action or crime of making a
false spoken statement damaging
to a person's reputation and
defamation, the action of
damaging the good reputation of
someone. Forgive me, Jamie. Are
you speaking about the minutes
from last board meeting? Yes.
And then I'm moving into, I
think you, I'm sorry. Awesome.
Yeah. That's the minutes of the
that are on the consent agenda
are actually from February 28th
and March 2nd. So. Okay. Okay.
So, just that in mind. Okay.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Um
okay. So, all of that then was
committed or meeting 2 weeks
ago. Um all that's been
recorded, all that's been sent
to a legal team because a group
who calls themselves mama bears
needs to be stopped. Um I
really enjoy the comments
though. Um they called me the
CCSD poster child and the CCSD
mascot. Um so, I brought a
costume tonight. Um I also
looked up how much a mascot
makes Um it's a little bit more
than what I make as a ten-year
teacher. Um with two master's
degree, a third one in the
works. Um in the process,
becoming a nationally
board-certified teacher. Um I
know there's a bingo card out
there tonight talking about how
much I'm going to talk about
myself so they can check that
off right now. Um
to your public comment. Well, I
love your flag. I'd like for
you to please continue with
your final comment. Thank you.
Um so, I just want to kind of
put that on. Um we definitely
are underpaid as educators in
Nevada so we should fix that.
Um the next one I want to talk
about, three oh three, the MOU
with the United Citizens
Foundation. Um this is an
excellent thing. If you haven't
read it in the minutes, I
suggest people go and read it.
Um several people have been
speaking for months about the
needs in our school for mental
health care. Um the only real
questions I and I know you
can't respond directly right
now. I just kind of want to put
it out there for future
consideration. Um I hope
someone can look into why it's
only 15 schools which is what
the agreement is for. Um
there's over 300 campuses in
CCSD. I know it's not possible
to roll this out to 300 schools
at once. Um but I wonder what
the criterion is to be chosen.
Like how are those 15 schools
going to be chosen? It's a two
year program. So is it designed
to be renewed? Um and will
fifteen schools be chosen next
May since the first 15 will be
chosen this May. Um so, if we
could get answers to those
questions in a subsequent board
meeting, I think the community
kind of deserves that. Mental
health clearly is an issue and
I've been called mentally ill.
Yeah, I am. I'm sitting here on
a flag when I could be home
with my cats having a microwave
dinner, okay? Cuz that's also
what they say. Um warrants,
three point zero five. Um so,
you might be wondering why I
brought up warrants. Um on page
four, my name is Les with a
$675 tuition reimbursement. So,
thank you for that. Um
genuinely, I mean, thank you
for that. Um it was from the
RPDP Library and Media Program.
So, thanks to RPDP. I've been a
certified school librarian
since January. Um it's really
exciting. I encourage teachers.
If that program is offered
again to do it, takes about a
year at seven classes. You
really learn a lot. Um one of
the lessons we had was about
how to buy books for
distribution in our library and
another on how to access the
resources across the district.
Um the district uses a program
called Destiny Discover through
Home Full It. And you can
actually access every library
in CCSD if you know how to use
it. And any school, librarian,
and all school should have a
librarian because of policies.
Um should know how to do that.
So that means we can look at
what books are and aren't in
CCSD. And because they came
with props tonight. I brought a
book from our library. Um and
since this is a huge issue, I
asked my librarian for the gays
book we possessed. Um and she
gave it to me. LBGBTQ rights
and activism. Cuz it's
something that our kids need to
know. Um but you'll notice a
couple of things. Um there's a
process for how we put the call
number on books. Every CCSD
library book has to have this
call number. Every CCSD library
book has to have the barcode.
Like there's literally a very
specific process to do this or
it can't be in the library. And
again any librarian can tell
you that Um so, when we have
people who come to the board
meeting with photocopies of
books that they claim are in
the library, if it's really in
the library, they can go check
it out. Their kitty can check
it out. Um if it's really in
the library, literally, anyone
who has a CCSD Email can look
up any book that is in the
system and is not in the system
and I think we need to be
really cautious of the fact
that you have bad actors coming
and accusing our librarians of
having books that don't exist.
Um what is that referenced when
it comes to the consent. and
then three point six and three
point seven. I'm going to
kind of combine those. It's the
licensed personnel, unified
personnel. Um we know that
we're hemorrhaging staff. Um I
know this, you know this, the
nation knows this. $4, 000
truly isn't enough to move here
when they see the abuse played
out on their screens. Um I know
tons of great teachers who are
leaving the profession
entirely. Um when I came here
in two thousand and fifteen,
they offered us $5, 000 and
even then people are like, oh,
that's not really enough,
right? It was enough for me to
get out here but it wasn't
enough for a lot of people but
now, it's offering four
thousand. Now, the criteria has
changed like they have to be
dedicated to be here at least 2
years. I don't think it's going
to work. Um I know plenty of
great teachers who are leaving.
I know teachers who were
going to be here tonight who
found themselves last minute
Not being able to be here. But
I think it's really time that
we take a seriously seriously
look at what it's going to take
to keep teachers here. Um
because it's not bringing new
teachers in for $4, 000 when
nationwide teacher programs are
ending because there's not
enough students to go into
those programs. Um it's not
enough when we constantly see
our pay frozen or when the CU
system is so difficult to
navigate that people give up
and can't access their raises
when they're putting in the
educational work to get those
raises. Um I think we really
need to look at that. I think
we need to look at who is
coming and speaking against
teachers at these meetings who
think because they have kids
that they're an educational
expert. Right? I think we need
to put look at what is being
put out online what is being to
be said into this boardroom and
in the lobby of this building
and in the bathrooms of this
building because your teachers
are under attack and and we're
leaving, you know, like it's
it's not it's not worth it to
have my children's advocate
tell me to kill myself in the
bathroom. Um so, last thing, I
know we're almost out of time.
Um one of my friends, she was
sick. She couldn't make it. She
Emailed you. Um so, it's in
the, it's in the board
documents already. Um I we need
to be really aware that when a
person gets thrown out of this
boardroom because they're
screaming about genitalia that
we don't have a trustee taking
pictures with them the next day
because reference to mister
thank you for your time at this
time I'd like to invite miss
Bautista back to the podium to
speak on we have five items
Bautista Oh. One, two, three,
four.
It's okay with the job and so
any chance I get to be super
silly, I appreciate it. Forgive
me, miss Wattis, I need to
correct something. I mentioned
Autumn would be next but it's
actually Jessica Allen and
then, miss Tampa. Thank you.
It's welcome. Interesting 'cuz
I saw the paper and the paper
had me next but I will allow
it. Yes, you are, you are next.
You are next. I meant after
you. It is Jessica and then,
miss Tampa. Then, I apologize.
You're okay. Thank you for
keeping us accountable. I will
own it. When I am wrong, I am
wrong and I will own it. Nope.
I'm always one moment while we
restart your time. Sure. Thank
you. Sorry. Welcome Um Diana
Bautista, special education
advocate for the record. Um
three. 04, I have a concern.
So, the approval process phase
three. Um I would appreciate if
any trustee could maybe clarify
whether or not there was a
mention of cameras in
surveillance but they didn't
specify where. And so, I know
that we have cameras just about
anywhere. I know that there are
some updates. Sometimes, we
have cameras that don't work.
Really conveniently. Typically,
when our kids are getting
abused, unfortunately, but it
does come up. Um and so, in the
event that we are looking at
cameras in classrooms, I want
to ensure that we are looking
at ensuring that it's
everywhere So, I absolutely
support our staff members being
safe 100 percent. I think
that's really important. We
want to keep our staff here. We
want to ensure that they're
safe. Um in addition to that,
too though, I want to ensure
that our children are also kept
in the back of our mindset.
When we're looking at these
things, we're looking at not
just staff safety but student
safety also. Um there wasn't
clarification on that so I
wasn't sure if anybody can
maybe ask that. Um the other
thing, three point zero five.
Um as I was going through the
warrants and bills payable, see
on page four, CCSD finally
paid. Jamie Tedronski for a
copy of the gay agenda. Well, I
think the reimbursement was
quite low considering all the
things we could learn from the
gay agenda such as Love Always
Wins and Suicide Prevention. I
do hope to see the
reimbursement increases and we
see the gay agenda in all CCSD
libraries very soon. Um also,
3. 17, I noticed on page one,
we have an issue with the
establishment clause. So, I
don't know if you guys have
looked into that but there was
9two 00 dollars that went to
the Association of Christian
Schools. Um shocker, I found
it. I know you hate my guts.
But I did. Um this is going to
software for schools. So, when
reading the association's
mission statement, it exists to
strengthen Christian schools
and Christian educators
worldwide. A worldwide, you
might want to review that. So,
again, establishment clause
that was concerning for me. I
think that needs to be reviewed
as to why it is that we're
spending $9200 of federal
dollars that is going to a
Christian organization. So, we
are dollars. We have public
schools. Typically, that's for
private. I don't know why
that's going there but it is.
So, three pointoneeight. Um
purchase award in the amount of
sixty, I'm sorry, $640, 000
dollars for Rethink Ed to
address many supports for
students with autism. Um would
cost you zero dollars if we
just got the RBTs and BCBAs
that I have talked about over
and over and over again. Um we
can go and we can approve
software and programs and
things over and over and I do
think it's important for our
teachers and our staff. But the
problem is, well we're going
and we're approving all of
these programs. We're not
addressing the other barriers
in the classroom that are going
on. So, when our children have
behavior issues and we've, you
know, reduced the lynx
department who, by the way, are
not licensed RBTs like some of
our privates are. We're doing
all of these things. We're
approving program and program
and program and we're not
looking at why it is our
children are not learning and a
lot of this is barriers such as
behavior that's going on in the
classroom or just many
different things. We need to
address what these barriers are
and so if we can get RBTs that
are going to cost us zero
dollars and not be hitting our
budget so much, I would love if
we could do that. I think
that's definitely the board's
mission from what I've looked
at over the last few months,
really important. Again, we
just want to ensure that we are
getting the behavior under
control. Also, three point two
eight. So, lots of agenda items
for professional services and
architectural design agreements
to review, inspect, and modify
all these school sites but I've
come and spoken before the
board again over and over again
about the Variety Hot Box and
the illegal seclusion
enclosures that are going on. I
know they spoke to you about it
several months ago. I do notice
that of all the school sites
that are looking at being
reviewed, modified, looking at
the design, architecture, all
of the above. Variety is not in
there. So, as an action item, I
would like to receive variety
added in there. So, what is
going on at Variety and these
illegal seclusion enclosures
are absolutely illegal. It's a
major just federal violation. I
don't know why we have not
looked at it, why we're not
taking that more seriously, but
it is an issue. We've had, it
is literally made that The news
all the way to Washington, DC.
So, we've been three years
behind the behind, kind of
what's going on and again, I
know I've talked about it but
that is still not been address
Um also, three point fourseven.
So, we have three hundred and90
That looks like is in a
settlement agreement for due
process. I fully support it. I
think a lot of our children
unfortunately are not receiving
a free and appropriate public
education. Um it affects not
only our students, it affects
every other student in the
classroom. It affects our
teachers. It affects the entire
classroom environment, the
school environment, all of the
above. So, if we aren't
going to provide fade by fully
support the 390, 000 and that's
it. Thank you. Thank you, miss
Bautista. It's just Ellen, you
have two items
Jessica Allen is not present.
Okay, we're going to move on to
miss Autumn Tampa who has one
item. You have two items. Thank
you, miss Tampa. And then we're
going to move on to yellow
cards after Miss Tampa. We have
Sarah Comrowe and
Nicolas. Oh, forgive me. It's
just Sarah Conroe for now.
Thank you, miss Tampa. Welcome.
Thank you. Autumn Tampa
speaking is an individual. Um
I'm glad that we've got a few
new employees coming on as
opposed to a whole bunch
leaving. It's kind of nice to
see. Um I've been here a long
time. I've experienced working
with and near and around a lot
of different a lot of different
principles and administrators
because I've was working as a
substitute teacher first in
over 150 schools and then after
that was an ELL tester and I
worked in 160 schools during
that job and that's because we
went to different schools for
the testing yearly. And so I've
had a lot of experience. Um I
recently have a new principal
at a school that I'm now being
surplused out of. Um who is
really very unique. Um and when
I first met him we kind of
butted heads. But as we got to
know each other his whole
attitude and disposition and
the way that he communicates
with children and a is very
very refreshing and I guess
that's what I'm trying to say
is that I have noticed that I
would say at least 80% of the
administrators that I have
communicated with and dealt
with most of my career. I've
pushed my way through. But most
of my career have almost like a
script that they follow. And
their responses to you as an
employee. And I'm sure that
they have a script they follow
in responses to children. And I
think other people have touched
on that. And That whole
perspective needs to change.
Not just the culture for
employees but the culture for
employees is the same one that
administrators have for
children and there needs to be
an openness, an acceptance that
everybody has talked about here
in so many different ways. And
the rigidity, the
regimentation, it needs to be
let go. You know, if COVID
taught us anything, it was that
life is short and precious. And
being in a school and being
alive with people and learning
is a gift. And we're missing
We're going back to all the old
ways. And you know we're
connecting it now to teachers.
You've got teachers leaving.
instead of teachers being
hired. I don't know what what
vast numbers in May it's
going to happen. But there's
1500 teachers positions open
and about 600 support staff. I
don't know how many
administrators because that
doesn't show up on my my job
job thing. But that's a serious
problem. That's a serious
problem. And I think it can be
fixed with all of the different
that we here have been saying
but we keep banging our heads
against the wall and maybe some
of you listen but there's not a
concerted effort. There's not a
joint, massive effort to hear
what people are saying to you
and and I think the parents,
some of them, they have their
emotions. Yeah, there's some
some groups but a lot of
parents have concerns. We're
all partners. We're all
together in this. No one is way
up here as far as their
humanness. We are all human
beings. We all have hearts and
souls. We all have gifts,
talents, abilities. We're all
unique individuals and we
should all be respected for
that and that is not happening.
It's not happening to teachers.
It's not happening with
principals. It's not happening
with support staff. And it's
not happening with students.
And I'm seriously concerned. I
almost walked out Monday. I
almost quit my job. And I had
to take a deep breath because
they can't afford it. And
that's happening not just
because of COVID. But it's
happened to me throughout my
career because of the the the
lack of kindness. The lack of
empathy. The lack of upset
acceptance that I feel as a
human being. And that I see
others feeling. I see children
feeling. And and I I don't know
how else to say it. I feel like
I've said it a million times
over. But I want to see action.
I want to see something being
done. Not just a little bit
social, emotional training. No.
More. You need more. Thank you.
Thank you, miss Tampa For
reminding us of our joint
humanity. At this time, oh,
forgive me. We have miss Comro.
Thank you. And We have four
items. Uh miss Commer, we have
three point 0 six, 3. 07, three
point three four, and three
point fourseven.
Welcome. Thank you. Sarah Comro
for the record. Um I want to
start with three point three
four. Upgrading the air
conditioning at Rancho High
School where I work. So
awesome. Very exciting. And at
the same time the last time we
had worked on at Rancho, our
carpets were replaced in
November. Um and they broke
large amounts of stuff in my
class worth hundreds of
dollars. That I had been told
to leave where it was because
it was on wieldly. And then I
was told for months that they
would replace it and then they
didn't. So, while we're
approving all these people to
come in and do work, I just ask
that we make sure that they're
not jerk faces who break stuff
and then don't replace it after
they promise to. Um moving on
to 3point47, another special
education settlement which
seems to be the the super fun
run of the mill here. If you
took all the money that you
spend on settlement and all the
money that you spend building
up a wall of lawyers that you
use to infringe on the rights
of your special students and
take away their services and I
don't know, spent that money on
actually providing a good and a
fair education for these kids,
then, maybe, we would actually
have a successful school
district. Speaking of special
education, I want to look at
three point18 and the amazingly
silly and wonderful miss Diana
Bautista. Um was talking about
the Rethink Ed purchase and how
we need to look at the
causation. So, when we do
stuff, in classrooms, in
special education classrooms,
we do something called ABC. Um
you look at the antecedent,
then you look at the behavior,
and then you look at the
consequence and it helps you to
see why it happened, what we
can change, or how we can
support to better it. But we're
not doing that as a district.
Instead, like she said, we are
just purchasing this,
purchasing that, slap a band
aid on. But if we pause and we
really looked at what the, the
problem is, what the antecedent
is, what the thing that is
happening is the behavior and
then the consequence which is
we're having these struggles
then we would be able to
actually find solutions that
are working as opposed to just
putting a little band-aid on
giant open gaping wound. Um and
taking that and kind of
swinging it up into three point
oh six and 3. 07 in conjunction
with 3 point1 eight. Teacher
Health Trust actually just
dropped services for autistic
kids. From their teachers being
able to get services for our
kids. And so instead of $10 per
service. It now costs $150. And
these are services that kids
often need daily, five days a
week. Um I know when my son was
getting it, he was going to
school full day and then going
home and doing three hours a
night. I can't afford $1 50 a
day, five days a week, four
weeks a month Because I'm a
teacher in Clark County School
District. I can't even afford
to give $5 worth of change to
my students when they ask. Um
And so I think you really need
to think about that because
these kids they're not, it's
not just that these kids are
human beings, which I know some
of you up on the days, may not
look at special education kids
that way, is what it seems, by
your statements on social
media, but they are. They're
human beings. But so are their
parents, right? Um, and they
are, we're all trying to work
hard for this district. And we
can't do that if our kids are
not being supported. And by the
way, they're your kids too.
Because they are Clark school
district students who are now
regressing in speech,
regressing in behaviors because
for one month, they are not
able to get services because
you don't pay us enough to pay
a 50 per service and let you,
yet, you let our health
insurance falter to the point
where they no longer cover
these necessary services for
our children to be clear, our
children because they're yours
too. Um and then, Now on to the
actual speech I wrote for 3. 06
and 3. 07 To discuss some of
the reasons why Clark County
School District employees are
fleeing into the wind. In my
class, I spend a lot of time
and effort creating a welcoming
class culture. My students know
that they can come to me for
anything and about anything.
They know that I will support
them and work with them to make
sure that they are safe,
healthy, and at and happy as
possible. And that they are
able to access their education.
To top it off, painstakingly
decorate my room with
affirmations, positivity, and
things that signify it as a
safe and supportive space for
all students. Oh, no. I forgot
the thing. Um one of my peers
brought me these because I they
knew that I would know who
would appreciate them.
It is a rainbow sticker to put
on our door that says safe
space. Oops. I thought to
myself, I should bring one for
you all here. And then I
realized this isn't a safe
space. This isn't a safe space
for our students. This isn't a
safe space for our staff. This
isn't a safe space for families
or community members. This
wasn't a safe space last June
for our students of color as
you all allowed racism to be
amplified for hours on end.
This wasn't a safe space last
meeting as you allowed a
homophobic and transphobic
comment to be thrown around the
boardroom including a freshman
in the student section being
called the F slur by an
audience member that have
repeatedly showed disdain for
the decorum supposedly required
in this room. This hasn't been
a safe space for as far back as
I can remember. Well, we all
hear you repeatedly, misgender,
and use incorrect titles for
LGBTQ plus staff who come to
speak. It's mixed and their
pronouns are they them. Which
by the way you misuse literally
90 seconds after they said that
they were thankful that their
admin used the correct
honorrithic and pronouns last
meeting Anyways, displaying
this sign here in this room
would be false advertising and
there's no amount of lipstick
we can put on this pig to make
people think it's pretty in
here. Thank you.
Our next ladies and gentlemen,
I don't want to have to remind
the audience that this is,
well, I appreciate the
encouragement that takes place
through applause. It is
inappropriate. Uh we have miss
excuse me, Jashante Marshall.
Uh speaking on three point oh
two. Thank you. Welcome. Thank
you. Good afternoon, everybody.
I wanted to speak tonight. As
you know, I'm the co-founder of
eighteen sixty-five, No Racism
in schools and we do often
receive rapid requests for
response and advocacy as it
pertains to expulsions and I am
not here to bash anybody
tonight but I'm here to do is
to provide solutions, okay?
Number one, 1865 is going to be
sponsoring along with Lavassi
and National Action Network Las
Vegas canvassing for kids on
June 11th and I am asking for
every last one of the Trustees
to participate in canvassing in
your respective districts. Um
because we need to get out and
gain commitment from the
families. We will be equipping
the people with resource lists
as they encounter a need and
they knock at those doors. And
the purpose is to reduce the
expulsions and the behaviors
that are happening inside of
the schools. If we can talk to
the parents, meet the needs of
the parents, and gain their
commitment or guardians to the
the safety in schools next
year. We are ahead of the
curve. I also want to just and
I see it's 41 seconds. So I'll
try to be quick. But I want to
encourage just to take a moment
to recenter our focus.
Performance driven outcomes
have been absent from many
conversations post pandemic. It
is imperative that we go back
to the various plans and
policies already implemented.
And that we assess what we are
truly capable of as a district
at this point. Then create a
strategy that is effective and
able to drive quantifiable data
that has positive outcomes in
the area of student
achievement. In addition to
that, we have opportunities we
will continue to mitigate the
conversations that are not tied
to monthly performance metrics.
I'll send an email. Thank you
very much. Thank you. Thank you
Deshanti. Appreciate your time.
At this time I don't see
anymore yellow cards for
It looks like we may have, yes,
I already see that. I see that.
It's okay. No, you're good. I,
we have Miss Binder for one,
two, three, four Um, come on
up. Welcome. We didn't mean to
miss you but we're, thank you
for bringing Um, the attention.
Welcome to you. Um, madam
president, members of the
board, Doctor Jarra. Good
evening. If I cry, I win bingo.
So, because I was put up to the
challenge this evening before I
left the house. I came up with
lots of thoughts on our consent
agenda. I also have a couple on
four four items on the 4. 0
items. So, I'll see you back in
a few minutes too. Uh okay,
licensed personnel. saw I think
the Channel eight news article
today that a particular middle
school principal tried to hire
three of our J one teachers to
fill some vacancies in our
school and was told that she
could not do that. Um really
concerning since we have so
many outgoing and if we have
some willing to come and help
teach our students that we
probably should prioritize
hiring them. But not my
business. Maybe the new chief
of HR. You know for two 00 000
a year can figure that out for
us. Um three point oh eight. Um
all of my children constantly
relay that the food sucks.
They'll be coming over the
summer when they're not busy
with school to vent their
entire feelings about that. But
I just figured with all those
pretty agreements going out
there that and I and I see
comments out in the community a
lot that we should just get the
choice of having the PEBT
benefits and feed our own
children versus you guys trying
to scour all the disgusting
stuff that probably gets thrown
away. Uh three point18. Um I
did want to hit the speech,
language, OTPT, but I kind of
from a different angle. So, I
just had my youngest son's
annual IEP and I went back and
matched up his blogs compared
to his speech logs as you guys
know for two years in a row
now. He has not received his
speech minutes. I wasn't
shocked to find that none of
the dates that the speech
therapist logged in her
attorney's notes billing that
coordinated with any document
in my son's journal of when he
actually went to speech
therapy. So, when I called that
out, I wish I would have taken
a picture of the speech lady's
face. Um I did give her a lot
of grace that we all make
mistakes and thankfully, my son
has made improvement but I
really just know where to go
because they were going to try
to push him into almost full
gin at first grade next year.
Despite all of the assessments
saying he could not be even in
a kindergarten classroom. So,
thankfully, great principal. Um
so, I hope maybe one year, you
know, he's got what like 11
years left. Maybe one year,
he'll actually get his
services. I also though wanted
to point out that in the the
last reportable Mac audits that
I received because I'm super
curious about services that are
billable back to Medicaid,
right? I talk about this a lot
like we should be getting
reimbursed for services like
language therapy, that we are
awarding to a third-party
company. So, we have 6. 6
million going for speech
language therapy and we have
another just shy of 8. 4
million going for OT and PT.
For kids who aren't even
getting services. But if you go
back to the last quarter ending
June 20 21 of your MAC audit.
Excuse me one second. I want to
be very very accurate when I
report this. total spad
expenditures. Oh, I'm sorry,
September 21st, 2021, quarter
ending. Total expenditures were
about 66. 5 million dollars.
Total claimable was only about
882000. So, how are we awarding
like 13 million dollars for
outside services? And we're
only getting what back? So, I
think this goes back to where
we constantly talk about data
because I know you have to
report data to get those
reimbursed. So, I'm still
digging and I will keep you
apprised of what I find. Um 3.
51. Um our new chief HR lady,
miss Tolks, I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing that correctly. Um
is from Breeder, right?
Florida, sued her previous
district, over alleged sexual
allegations from a trustee
member. So, thankfully, we have
no men on our board right now.
Um also has claims of
retaliation, all kinds of
things and I really just
thought like, why would she
come here? Like, why? Are we
setting ourselves up for
another lawsuit? Because it's
all over the place here and
she's inclined to be a
whistleblower. So, I do like
that about her. So, I look
forward to her future claims.
Let's see. Actually, that's all
I have. Thank you so much. Our
last public commenter on
consent agenda items is mister
David Korman. David.
Trustee Williams here in the
queue. Is that when we're, it's
okay. No worries. I know. I
thought. Thank you. You're fine
there. Thank you. Welcome. Good
evening. Good evening. Good
morning. Garcia Morales and
other Trustees, Superintendent
Harra. I'm David Corma, I'm a
candidate for district F. I
want to discuss the 3. 51
employment agreement for the
Chief Human Resources Officer.
Kinda got hit by somebody else
right before me here. So, she
was a nice sway in for me. Uh
if you remember last past
Tuesday night, there was a
district F candidate format
Windmill Mar or Windmill
Library. I that the trustees
don't have the same mindset as
Trustee Ford when she made her
comment to the question by
Timothy Lane Carmen Chandler.
This is specifically about
three. five one. I'd like for
you to keep your comments
specific to that. Thank you.
Alright. Um she made a comment
that's that stated a comment
that stated something about
there is no problem with with
employees or employee there is
no problem with employees in
the district. And we know that
that's not true. Um we know
that the many employees are
leaving this year. Uh then that
result is from that all of our
teachers leaving this year is
that they're going to be
continue to fall behind. And
are basically in the last in
the in academically. So we all
know that CS CCSD has to change
their mindset. I know that the
majority of you on this board
don't think that way. You think
that our employees are
important and that they need to
be so that this person who's
coming in Doctor Toll, she's
going to be responsible for all
human resources and all the
processes and and procedures
within. Therefore, I hope you
guys took the time to possibly
look at her background because
it is critical. It's a critical
decision and it's going to make
it's probably the biggest
decision this board is going to
make. for you here as well as
probably what has happened in
the last 16 years of of CCSD. I
hope you took the time to to go
back and research, do your due
diligence as to her background
and as talking to Doctor Hara
as well because they work
together in Florida. So, I hope
you did your due diligence and
and I thank you for your time.
Thank you, David. At this time,
do we have a motion to adopt
the consent agenda? I see
Trustee Williams in the queue.
Thank you, Madam Vice
President. At this time, I'd
like to make a motion to adopt
the consent agenda. Thank you.
Do we have a second?
I second We have a motion by
Trustee Williams. A second by
Trustee Guzman. Trustees please
cast your vote. Trustee Brooks.
Aye.
that motion passes. I do that
again. Six to zero. I'm noting
that Chelsea said President
Zabeda is absent today. Thank
you very much, Trustees. We are
now moving on to
the warrants. Trustee Brooks.
Are you available to read the
warrants? I am. Uh ratified
warrants as listed in the
bills, payable, transmetal, and
board memorandum. Number 18
dash 21 dash twenty-two in the
total amount of one hundred
twenty-five million three
hundred ninety thousand four
hundred ninety-eight dollars
and sixteen cents. Thank you,
Tracy Brooks. At this time,
we're going to move on to 4.
01. Focus 2024 strategic plan
update on chronic absenteeism
and I see that Doctor Barton is
joining us. Doctor, along with
Doctor Ansalone, welcome. Thank
you so much for being here this
evening. Gentlemen, we will
turn the presentation over to
you and then we'll have public
comment. Thank you very much.
Thank you
madam vice president.
Members of the board, Doctor
Jara. Uh this evening, we are
providing an update according
to our Focus 2024 strategic
plan. Uh again, the board has
seen this presentation in
previous forms and I'll go get
to the dates where you saw
previous updates. Uh but again,
this aligns to student success
and specifically safety and
engagement, chronic
absenteeism. And so this is
aligned to again, the focus
2024 plan, which is made up of,
of several components for
accountability. Again, as a
refresher of Trustees, there
have been multiple
presentations in the last
several years on chronic
absenteeism. Uh the latest
being on February 10th 2
thousand 22, when we provided
an update regarding semester
one, chronic absenteeism rates.
Uh, with your permission, madam
Vice President, I'll turn it
over to Doctor Ansello.
Absolutely, welcome. Good
evening, Vice President
Morales. Members of the board,
Doctor Jara, John Ansalone,
assistant superintendent ESD
for the record. Um, just a
refresh as the the definition
that we follow for chronic
absenteeism, chronic
absenteeism is a school quality
measure on the Nevada school
performance Framework that
captures the total percentage
of students who are absent for
10% or more of their enrolled
days. Our theory of action has
stayed consistent. Um we
believe that if we identify
root causes for miss school
situations and use outside
partners to assist with chronic
absentee efforts, then we will
increase connectedness on
campuses. So, here in front of
you, you see a breakdown of our
student groups. Um the data
shows that we're continuing to
see increases in our chronic
absenteeism. Essentially,
across the board with one
bright spot in our black
African-American student group
where there was a 1 percent
decrease over time and you can
take a look at that.
and also
looking at our
targets, we are, we haven't hit
our targets for this year.
We're above our targets in all
all areas. Um with our
brightest spot being our Asian
student group, with a 20%
actual target. Our chronic
absenteeism gap overall results
and status, this is the gap
between the highest and lowest
student groups in chronic
absenteeism in percentage
points. Our target was 9. 3%
and currently we're at 28
percent in that gap.
looking at like district
districts within our state and
across the country. Um
currently, we are on par with
other like districts. Um so
we're not alone in this. Um if
you look at Denver and Miami
Dade, we're just about the same
as them as far as our
percentages and interestingly
enough, Washoe County is is a
little bit higher than ours
right now. Um so, again, this
shows that this is not just a
statewide problem or district
problem but a nationwide
problem. So, what are some of
our challenges, our successes,
and lessons learned? Um we know
that we're still in the
distance ed aftermath and and
so the challenges are are in
that area as well as absence
reporting, consistency across
the board. Our successes, we
have strong partnerships as you
know, and they're very very
willing to support. We've been
working very collaboratively
with them and also, we have
targeted support during the
school closure and our
attendance officers have done a
phenomenal job and we've
increased our our in that in
that department Lessons
learned, we obviously have seen
that chronic absenteeism
impacts all indicators across
the board and our recovery from
increased rates will require
ongoing comprehensive
initiatives. Which we'll share
with you here on this next
slide. So our next steps as you
know, beginning in April and
continuing through the rest of
this school year into June. Um
we've been having our student
focus groups feedback sessions.
We're calling student voices.
Uh it's been an outstanding
opportunity us to as our team
has met with students across
the valley and all the trustee
districts. Um we found some
emerging themes. Um we have
found that students really like
attendance incentives and they
like for many of those to come
back and and I think we heard
from a student today that that
mentioned that as well. Um we
know that students are asking
for strong tier one
instruction, engaging lessons
that will entice them to come
to school and be more motivated
and of course connectedness.
We've talked about that before.
Connectedness with one or more
adults on campus. Our students
have that they have goals and
dreams. They they like to come
to school. However, life has
happened. Um family matters.
Work. We've talked to students
that actually help provide
medical attention to their
parents and grandparents and so
they stay home to provide pills
and other medications for the
families. Um they also seem to
have adult priorities right now
which I'm sure we can empathize
with. Students like little
things like welcomes and and
good things that we may take
for granted sometimes and
positive reinforcements
throughout the day. And again
connecting to at least one or
more adults on campus. We will
continue our work with the
truancy prevention outreach
program or TPOP. We feel like
we continue to have a strong
relationship and partnership
with the county specifically
Teapop. Um we've provided
additional staff using grant
fundings. Um and again the five
harbors have been an
outstanding talking point for
us and and we've used them
throughout the district and
throughout the valley. Uh my
brother's keeper and SJP,
school justice partnership have
also been outstanding
partnerships in this area. And
lastly, we plan in August in
the fall to continue to provide
differentiated attendance
reporting PL for our clerks and
registrars which has already
begun and onboarding anybody
new coming on so they can
understand the attendance
coding process in a
comprehensive way. third one.
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Doctor Jara, that
concludes our presentation just
to highlight what the data
included this evening. Again,
this is an update through
quarter three. Uh we will be
coming back to the board with a
cumulative look at the entire
school year regarding chronic
absenteeism and we're we're
happy to address any questions
you may have this evening.
Thank you, Doctor Barton. Thank
you, Doctor Anselom. Uh this
I'm going to turn it over to
Trustees. I see Trustee
Williams is in the, forgive me.
thank you so much for that
reminder. Um Trustee Guzman, we
have a couple of before we go
on to questions, we have some
public comment. We'll start
with individuals who have
registered in advance and that
is Autumn Tampa, and we have a
4. 01, chronic absenteeism, and
then we have Miss Binder. Thank
you. Welcome.
Autumn Tampa, speaking as an
individual, just so you know, I
was sick for 2 weeks Then, I
was sick a couple months ago
for 2 weeks. So, I'm still
being careful. Um you know, I I
was really surprised to see
this on the agenda. I know did
you hit the time button? I
said, I I could use the extra
time. Um I never get any. So,
anyways, prior to COVID, there
was a problem with absenteeism
and I know that I did speak
about that a few times. I know
I lived in an apartment complex
with a family. The father work
tonights in a band and the
mother work days as a maid. So,
she had to leave the house at
seven o'clock and I usually
left around the same time and
if the husband didn't come home
from his night work, then, the
junior high students stayed
home to take care of the
toddler. So, I mean, there
wasn't really any other answer.
Survival was what was important
and I, you know, I I keep
mentioning because during the
recession, a lot of services
were cut for aid for families
in need for childcare and that
sort of thing. Um I know that
Even after COVID, I've had
students say, well, I had to
stay home to take care of my
brother or sister. Um my mother
was sick and I had to take care
of her. Uh so, there's all of
that. I know when I worked at
another junior high school as
long-term sub, there was a girl
that had a crush on a boy who
was cutting and so she kept
cutting because of him. So,
there's lots of different
reasons why people cut. Um I
think the numbers are skewed
because of COVID. I I'm I
couldn't believe that we were
even calculating number because
I don't want sick children
coming to school. They get me
sick. And now I've got children
afraid to go to the nurse
because they don't want to get
in trouble for going home. So,
I don't know what the district
is going to do because to me,
it's a nationwide problem.
We'll go to school, go to work
if you're sick, it's okay,
tough it out. I think that's
the wrong answer. because you
get everybody else sick and you
hurt your body. So, I don't
know. There should be a focus
of getting kids who are not
sick into school but not making
who are sick come to school so
numbers are up and that's the
serious problem that I see and
have seen for the whole time
I've been in the district.
Thank you. Thank you Miss
Tampa. At this time I'd like to
invite Miss Binder to come up
to speak on four. 01. Looks
like we also have Miss Comrowe
on 4. 01 and Miss Camilla
Bywaters. Welcome back. Thank
you. Thank you. Uh Madam
President, members of the
board, Doctor Jara. Um so, I've
been talking about this for
like a year.
I cannot
wait to see the actual
data on why kids are missing
school. Uh over the course of
next week, there will be
several truancy graduations
happening across your campuses.
And these are kids that we've
had the pleasure of mentoring,
getting to come to school,
getting them to believe in
themselves, to raise them above
passing. And for a lot of these
students, the new grading
system worked out really well
for them. What's very
concerning in in the
presentation is that forty-six
point7% of those chronically
absent were our IEP kids. So
now we have a whole bunch of
money going out the door to a
whole bunch of kids who aren't
getting services and almost
half of them aren't even coming
to school. Where's the money?
Alright, let's go. Thank you,
miss Bunder. Uh Sarah Conroe.
and then miss Bywaters Camilla
Bywaters. Welcome back. Thank
you. Thank you. Sarah Conroe
for the record. The young
scholar that spoke earlier I
believe named Jacob. On the
tardy policy impacting chronic
absenteeism. I made a really
good point. We should be
getting them to want to be on
time. Earlier up here they
spoke about positive
reinforcement and connecting
them to at least one or two
teachers. Great ideas. If we
had the staff to create that
school culture. In case you
haven't noticed we're a little
low. Uh so I just my students
to be on time to comro cash
dollars and that's worked
really good. But I'm curious
what the focus is going to be
next year regarding chronic
absenteeism. When we're short
and extra I believe it's 1400
student teachers is where we're
sitting right now. I also
wanted to add to this and say
that your SSD department, your
special education services
department. Um when they come
in and they assess a child with
special education services for
a change of placement or for
additional support. So, higher
levels of support. Somebody who
has never met that child or
somebody who has only seen that
child for 1 hour gets to make a
decision about that child's
placement. Instead of the IEP
team which is the federal
requirement. Um and that is
because the the is scared of
retaliation and the excuse that
they often give is we cannot
support a change of placement
or more supportive services,
higher services because that
child has chronic absenteeism.
Well, when that child had
COVID, twice, last semester.
Now, they have chronic
absenteeism. And I think that
the teacher that's with them, 7
hours a day, multiple days a
week, even if it's not all
five, right? Even if they're
chronic absent, they still know
better. So, that's a huge
problem we have with the
chronic absenteeism situation.
Thank you so much. Thank you,
miss Conroe. I'd like to invite
miss Camilla Bywaters to the
podium.
Welcome. Okay, Camilla
Bywaters, president of the Las
Vegas Alliance of Black School
Educators. Um so, after
listening to that presentation,
I noticed that the only
minoritized population that was
announced were for our black
students and I believe I saw
the numbers were kind of blurry
and small but I believe I saw
about 48. 1 percent for our
black African-American
students. Um the numbers are
definitely high. For our minor
populations and including
students with disabilities
which is really interesting
because they're not in school.
That sounds like some lawsuits
right here. But there has to be
an evaluation of how the
programs that we currently
have. Um are operating and if
they're truly doing the work
that we're saying that they're
doing. Um absenteeism has not
all of a sudden popped up in
our district. It has been an
issue and has only been
exacerbated by the pandemic. Um
So, I, we are asking that, we
really look into our
partnerships, evaluate the
effectiveness of those
programs, and determine if
they're really providing the
services that we need for our
students 'cuz it seems that we
really need some intense
services. When I was teaching
in CCSD and back in the day, I
often had conversations with my
black students who often feel
alienated and that they don't
have a voice within their
education and often times, they
struggle with their white
teachers. They struggle with
teachers who do not understand
their culture, their
backgrounds, and how who they
are impacts their educational
experiences. Um I would hope
that we're incorporating
culturally responsive
pedagogies as well into our
practices so that we can
encourage our students to come
to school so they can value
themselves by seeing themselves
within the curriculum. and I
forgot.
Thank you, Camilla Bywaters. I
have Diana Bautista who is also
signed up for 4. 01.
Um Diana Bautista for the
record. So, I'm a little bit
surprised because this has
caught my attention for months
and months and I I don't even
think you guys sometimes
realize the significance
sometimes of the statements
that you make and so, months
ago, we talked about the
chronic truancy and the fact
that in that data, after all of
that data out, I don't trust
any of it and unfortunately, a
lot of it is because we're
sitting here and we're
suspending kids and we're
addressing behavior issues or
whatever it might be and we are
then punishing our kids
behaviors but then we're also
at the same time marking them
as chronically and I don't
understand why that is. Um
additionally, many of our
families which is not typically
discussed or thought about,
which surprises me, is the fact
that many of our kids who are
chronically joint, may have
medical issues. Um, we don't
talk about supplemental
services and what that looks
like in an IEP, and the
additional supports and
services that we can offer
students who are chronically
true at. Um, my son is one of
them, that receives those
services. I'm very thankful of
it. Um, but I can also tell you
that since he's come back to
school, he hasn't gotten one
hour of it. Shocker. Um I don't
know where the teachers are,
where the staff are that are
giving these services but when
we're sitting here, we're
looking at these numbers. a lot
of times there are extenuating
circumstances that I don't
think is always addressed
before the board. Some of that
is because they are
immunocompromised or they may
have additional medical issues.
I know that like my oldest son,
when my youngest son is out
because he's sick, he's afraid
that he's going to go and he's
going to take COVID or
something else at that point to
his one-to-one who is maybe a
little bit older. I'm like
trying to think of the words
here but without being I guess
offensive. But so he's you know
some of our kids are they're
just afraid. They're afraid
that you know because the
younger one is sick. I had a
teacher that informed me this
morning that they're out sick
right now because of COVID.
They tested positive this
morning. My first instinct is
when was the last time that you
worked with my child? Because I
have to worry about my youngest
son who's immunocompromised. So
that's it. Thank you. Thank
you. Miss Bautista. We have
Brend Zamora who's also signed
up for 4. 01.
Welcome. Hello. For the record,
Brenda Zamora. I just quickly
wanted to share as I was
listening to the presentation,
my kid's story. So, as we're
hearing, you know, awarding
children who have perfect
attendance, it sounds awesome
and everything but I think
about my children who
unfortunately, you know, the
first week when school started,
my oldest just went, you know,
had surgery. She was out for 2
weeks. She was admitted in the
hospital and two weeks after
that, we got in a major car
accident and we were out for
about a month because I was
septic and I was in the
hospital and I just couldn't
help my children get to school
at that point. and I think
about them in their situation
of things that they just have
no control about. You know,
this is stuff that it's not
their fault. It's nobody's
fault. It's just life happens.
Just like how everyday adults,
you know, things happen. Um and
then in December, of course, we
get COVID. So, we were out
another month. So, it's just
she's had 10 surgeries. She is
immune compromised, you know,
and I think about even when she
start to fever, she starts
anything, I do pull her out of
school because I don't want it
to get worse. I don't want, you
know, someone else to probably
who's starting something just
spreading because we all know
elementary school students,
they, just full of viruses,
right? And that's something we
all know. Um but it, I think
about her possibly sitting in
in this attendance, you know,
certificate ceremony and how
she just might feel some type
of way, right? And I just want
to let you all know that I know
my story is not the only one.
As I talk to people, they have
similar stories. We just saw a
comment about someone who they
had COVID twice this year
already, you know? So, it's
just things that just happen
and we just have to think about
that as we think about perfect
attendance is not you're
creating this idea and we have
support staff who don't have
paystick days either, you know,
who can't take a sick day off
because they can't afford that
day with no pay. So, it's just
so much that goes into it and I
don't like this idea of you get
a certificate for being
perfect. That's not what
reality is. Thank you. Thank
you, miss Amora. We have
Arianne Pritchard. Ariana,
Ariana, Richard. Welcome.
It's Arianne like Mary Ann
without the M. Arianne. Arianne
Pritchard for the record.
Welcome. I am a teacher in this
district. I'm a 14-year veteran
teacher and this year has been
the worst year for attendance
that I have ever experienced.
and then the bomb was dropped
on my high school students that
next year that they would start
at 7 AM. 45 minutes earlier
than their start time. And it's
already a difficult time for
them to get to school. I was
having students with
transportation issues earlier
this year. Those seemed to have
been mitigated slightly. But
when I was covering for another
teacher's class because you
know I don't get a prep. Um
what the upperclassmen were
saying is well since school
starting 45 minutes earlier and
classes are 45 minutes long.
I'm just going to miss my whole
first period. So I want to say
that that unilateral
operational decision to start
nearly every high school at 7
AM is going to negatively
impact attendance and increase
truancy especially in many of
our high schools. And that's
all. Thank you so much At this
time, we have no more public
comment for 4. 01 and I'd like
to turn it over to my
colleagues who have questions.
I see Trustee Williams is in
the queue.
Thank you Madam Vice President.
Thank you, Doctor Ansalone and
Doctor Barton. I have just a
couple questions. Um again, I'd
like to state that and you guys
can, we are not the ones that
make up the definition of
chronic absenteeism. That's the
state. So, I would suggest to
parents and teachers and
community members to go lobby
with the legislators and change
the definition because I
understand that life happens
and in 2020 and 2021, a lot of
students had to leave school
because they took on jobs
because they became homeless
which for whatever their
absenteeism went up and so
that's one of my questions is
do you guys plan on working
with the legislators for the
next legislative session to
help change that definition so
it these numbers actually
become a little bit more
accurate?
Doctor Jara?
Go ahead doctor. Thank you.
Thank you, madam president.
Members of the board, I have
mister Manzi come in as this is
part of how we assess and hold
schools accountable from the
State Department. I know
there's some conversations
about mister Mansey will be the
appropriate staff. Thank you.
Welcome. Thank you. Um Madam
Vice President, members of the
boards who were intended to
jar. Greg Mansey, assistant
superintendent for the record.
Um we are following the federal
guidance that defines chronic
absenteeism. So, that is what
word to in terms of the
business rules and the
calculations here. Absent is
absent and close towards the
calculation and the 50% or more
for a day. Sure. I I and I 100%
understand that I guess my my
question was I would hope that
the school district or
community members or anybody
they that they see this and
they understand that yeah life
happens to some of these
students beyond their control
and I agree that we should we
should incentivize students to
come to school regardless of
what's going on but sometimes
they just can't. So that was
when my and then my question,
my second question was for the
online students do you have a
array, a truancy rate, or an
absenteeism rate that is
counting that or or not? You
said that was one of your
challenges.
Go ahead, Doctor Martin. Thank
you. Uh thank you, Madam Vice
President. Members of the
board, Superintendent Jara. So,
the distance learning in fact
and mister Mansey can correct
me if I'm wrong. Uh they are
counted as present if they're
say quarantined and they're
provided with a distance
learning option. They are in
fact provided with a present
code. Um as far as
differentiating that from the
overall chronic absenteeism
number, that's difficult
because the overall attendance
coding is the same for all
attendance factors. Sure Okay.
Alright. That's all I have
questioned for. Thank you.
Thank you, Chelsea Williams. I
see Trustee Guzman is in the
queue. Go ahead, Jesse Guzman.
Thank you. Um I have just a
couple of questions. I'm really
happy that Comrode Dollars as
an incentive does work and that
was in our presentation. So,
I'm excited about that. Um but
I want to talk about the bus
issues where the bus issues
taken into account for
absenteeism or is it you just
mentioned to Trustee Williams
that it's just an absence is an
absence. Go ahead, Doctor
Martin. Thank you, madam Vice
President. Members of the
board, Superintendent Gerrard.
Trustee Guzman to your
question. Uh I know that this
year has been a challenge with
with some service providing
with the the bus shortage and
the driver shortage. Uh what
we've done is a district is
definitely we we encouraged our
principals working with their
teams that if there was a bus
that was arriving late, there
would be a leniency as far as
tardies. So, we definitely
worked with our principles on
that. We know that they use
sound judgment and if a bus
comes in obviously late. It's
not the child's fault. So, that
being part of the calculation,
we we worked with our
principals to ensure as much as
it could, that there was
leniency for those factors that
were beyond their control.
Okay, thank you. And then the
last question that I had has to
do with students that work. Um
during the pandemic, they had
to start working, right? Um
what accommodations have we
made for those students so that
they're not absent?
Go ahead. Doctor Barton. Thank
you, madam Vice President. Uh
members of the board, Doctor
Jar, Trustee Guzman, I think
it's a great question. I I
don't know if I have a precise
answer because it's it's a
complicated issue, right? Yeah.
So, I think that students that
are required to work at a time
that's unprecedented. Um how do
we accommodate for that with
the federal requirement with
chronic absenteeism? Right. Um
to be determined. That's why
we're doing these focus groups.
Okay. We keep talking to our
students. Uh Doctor Anzalone
has has done really good work
taking a deep dive with these
students to learn about their
issues and what preventing them
from coming to school and I
think that's that was a fact
that was brought up several
times with Doctor Anne's loan.
We're going to continue to do
that work and and talk to the
students in this focus group
setting to learn from them what
can we do to be more
accommodating within the
federal requirements and so we
definitely want to keep talking
them and learning and the other
thing is I I think that you
know the superintendent always
makes us aware of national
research and how this is
impacting the whole country. So
three big factors to consider
with a strategy
relational network. That's why
we're doing the focus groups.
The family engagement piece and
then also consistently taking a
deep dive into the trends that
we're seeing. So, the reality
is this, the trends that we've
been providing to you as as a
board in the last few months,
it's a different trend pre
pandemic. So, it's going to be
important that we continuously
do this, reflect on the data
that we're getting from the
focus groups and try to tackle
that kind of very tough
dynamic. Thank you. Sorry to
send you a Kurt Bild. I didn't
mean to. Thank you, Trustee
Guzman. I see that Trustee Ford
is in the queue. Go ahead,
Trustees Ford. Thank you so
much. Okay. So, can you just
clarify for me really quick
'cuz I've heard some students
speak about how being, you
know, relate to one class that
that, you know, 10 minutes
later, whatever, that that's an
absence but then, I just heard
that it's 50% of the day or
more. Can you just clarify that
exactly?
Go ahead, Doctor Mensey. Uh
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jara, Trustee Ford. So, the
attendance count codes are
applied per course. Um so, the
situation that was explained
earlier, that attendance code
was applied to that class that
may have been missed. The
overall calculation for chronic
absenteeism is 50% or more of
the day in totality. So, if a
student was absent or say tardy
to a class every single day,
let's say this. That was his
parent's schedule Actually,
I've kind of been in this
situation. We have multiple
kids and all their starting
times are like around the same
time. Let's say that they were
late to the first period every
day, 15 minutes, every day.
What would would it be like
every three charities as an
absent? Would it be there every
day they're there? They have no
absences or what would that be?
Doctor Mancy. Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, Superintendent Jara,
Trustee Ford, for the purpose
of the calculation, it looks at
each day in isolation. So, 15
minutes would be applied to
that student's schedule as a
absent time versus the present
time that would be our six-hour
and 11-minute day. So, they
wouldn't be, that's not a day
of being fully absent or 50% or
more for that student. So, it
wouldn't accumulate like you
wouldn't compound the 50
minutes to hit like half of a
day and then that would be the
absence.
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jar, Trustee Ford. Um for the
purpose of this calculation,
that's not how the, how it
factors in for the 15 minutes.
It's kept just to that day.
Okay, that's thank you. I I'm a
little have some questions.
I'll bring up with you later
because I actually have two
teenagers in school and I have
experienced what this student
was saying with my own
children. So, I think there
might be maybe some
misunderstanding. Um I've I've
to write notes to excuse
absences for a tardy that was
15 minutes after drop-off time.
So, You're saying for the
actually looking at chronic
absenteeism that those ones
would then be not included as
far as the presentation but it
would be counted for the
student. Doctor Mansey, I
believe that you've answered
the question several times. I
just want to maybe there's
another way to go there. Thank
you. Go ahead. Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, Superintendent Jar,
Trustee Ford. So, the situation
with the Tardies that that's a
that was applied to the course
and the time that's missed for
the course. So, we have certain
minutes that are attributed to
a class. They might be a
90-minute period. They might be
a 45-minute period. Um
depending on the time the
students able to spend present
in the course and attendance
code is applied if they were
absent fully for the period or
if they were tardy for the
period. We look at the total
minutes for the day to do the
purpose of the calculation
here. Three tardies, there may
be a policy at the school site
that does lead to other pieces
but that would be a tardy
accumulation, not for the of
the chronic absenteeism
calculation. Okay, I'm I'm
hearing the the response and
I've I'm understanding the
response. It just seems like
it's not lining up with my
personal experience. So, thank
you. I appreciate it. Um so,
this was a big issue pre-covid.
Uh we were discussing this at
Lanes with the Clark County
Commission. Uh I can
specifically remember putting
my back in it and I can see
teachers lining up with
solutions to this. Um the
commissioners saying, hey,
bring all ideas to the table. A
lot of teachers saying things
like, hey, give me some extra
money and I'll get these kids
to school in the morning. You
know, I'll hunt them down and
they're not going to tell me
no. Uh so, I I really would
like to almost like get back to
that place. Almost like, this
was already an issue where are
we compared to then? But that's
going to be really difficult
without being able to subtract
the chronic absenteeism that is
due to COVID whether sick,
quarantined, or directly
because of the effects of COVID
like taking on a second job and
what not so I guess I'm just
interested to see how can we
get those numbers as close as
possible to what it might look
like if COVID wasn't a thing.
Um have we considered maybe
surveying parents and families
just to say or maybe surveying
those that are chronically
absent and saying how many of
these days were COVID related
to get to some closer answer?
I'm making eye contact with me.
I believe that's that's you.
Doctor Barton. Uh go ahead
please. Thank you Madam Vice
President, members of the
board. Doctor Jara, Trustee
Ford, I I think it's it's a
complicated question. Again,
I'm I'm not trying to not give
a direct answer here but I
think to gather that kind of
information and make a
conclusion on what the COVID
impact was would be difficult.
Recall that pre-covid, we were
making progress. We were, we
still had a high chronic
absenteeism across the board
and even in particular student
groups but there was progress
to get to the point of multiple
agencies and that, you know,
you mentioned the county, we're
continuing to double down on
those partnerships. You know,
we, again, the timeline, Doctor
Ansloan went over. By June, we
expect a report from our Teapot
partnership with the county and
what that impact may have been
at the macro and micro level
because there's definitely some
interventions that they do at
particular schools and trying
to make an impact. Um but we
definitely have a lot of work
to do but concluding the impact
from COVID, I think we struggle
along with the other districts
we're talking to consistently,
our comparative districts.
We're just struggling to
conclude how dramatic that
impact was and so, our team
will continue to do, again,
take a deep dive in that data
as we develop trends and see
trends and bring it to the
board but that's the best that
we can do right now, Trustee
Ford. Thank you. It's a it's a
tough task. Things I've read,
says that we're not going to
have data until COVID is over,
probably 2 years after COVID is
completely over and we're still
in it. Uh last thing, it was
mentioned briefly by Doctor
Anzalone that one of the things
that keeps kids showing up to
school is the connecting to one
or more adults on campus. Um I
think that that should be
looked at deeper. I think
that's something that kind of
got glazed over but might be a
fundamental reason why kids do
or don't show up. Um I recently
spoke to the media and said
that it's my belief that before
we focus on recruiting new
teachers and staff that we
should put major efforts. and
resources into retaining our
current employees who have
already developed relationships
with students and who have who
have invaluable insights into
the unique needs in their
schools and the communities
that they serve. Uh so I I
really feel like that might be
a missing piece and some of the
things that I've read
nationally. Um mention that.
Mention that sometimes or not
sometimes a lot of times. The
only reason why a kid shows up
to school Is because they know
their an adult there. Who
cares? I'm good. Thank you.
Thank you, Joseph Ford. I see
Trustee Cavazos is in the
queue. Go ahead. Uh thank you,
Chelsea Garcia Morales. Um some
of my questions are been
already been asked by my
colleagues but I think what
we're talking about here and
you know, thank you for all
your work on this and for
bringing us these updates. Uh
they're very helpful along with
the briefings that we get on
this. I can't remember. I don't
think I asked this during this
particular briefing but some of
the comments from our
constituents Tonight. It seems
like, you know, we're talking
about life happens. You guys
are looking at, you know,
really a global outlook here.
The bottom line here, cutting
to the chase is that we need
our kids to be in school and
so, you're looking at not only
the symptoms of the absenteeism
but it looks like you're taking
a deeper dive into looking at
the root causes. So, my
question here would be in
looking at the comparisons that
you brought us and thank you
for that to the other
districts. Was there any one
Thing that you saw or that was
different and some like for
instance, Washo, a little bit
higher. Some of the other ones
I think you said, Doctor Barton
was at Denver and can't
remember the other one. I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. Miami Dade,
okay? That were very similar
with our numbers. Was there
anything that you could put
your finger on because I'm
hearing a lot of things from
the public commenters tonight
that you know, a lot of it had
to do with social, emotional
learning, some of the things
that were happening in their
lives, medical issues. Um I
mean, I'm just wondering if
there's any one particular
challenge or something that you
saw that was different. Doctor
Ansello. Thank you Vice
President Morales. Members of
the board, Doctor Jara, Trustee
Cavazos, great question. You're
100% accurate. The emerging
themes continue to show us that
students especially in some of
the larger urban districts like
Denver and Miami Dade. Um the
students were being looked to
for more of that support within
the family as opposed to
smaller districts or even you
know, less affluent districts
and so, I think that's
something that was a common
denominator that we found that
that that these students are
being needed by the family and
and their supports outside of
the school much more than
others. Thank you, Doctor
Anselon. So, kind of continuing
with that. Just kind of
piggybacking on that. Um I like
that you're not just looking
at, you know, just like
officers as being the be all
and the end all. It's just a
moving piece and the parts of
this. So, when we are looking
at those differences with other
districts, and again, I
want to, I want to sail Trustee
Guzman's here, Grace as far not
wanting to throw you a curve
ball here, and a question that
maybe I didn't think of during
the briefing, but would it be
probably to our benefit to find
out if possibly, could some of
these other districts that are
doing better with the
absenteeism rate? Did they
start on social, emotional
learning, maybe a little bit
sooner we did and and you know,
I know that our MTSS system and
looking at the different tiers
are absolutely important and we
have to kind of take in stages.
I know, there are many
conversations with Doctor
Barton but would that be
something that possibly in the
future that we could look at?
Doctor Bart? Uh thank you. Um
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Doctor Jarra,
Trustee Cavazos. I think it's a
fair question that we've
learned from our partnering
districts that there's
definitely, definitely a
difference in for pupil There's
a difference in definitely one
stages of SEL was implemented
or even a a mental health
ecosystem to support students.
Um while we had efforts in the
Clark County School District or
even in the state of Nevada
before the pandemic, I think
that that create a magnifying
glass to create a sense of
urgency where we're now we're
partnering with multiple
agencies, Care Solace,
Telehealth through Hazelhealth,
to expand it on all campuses,
but I definitely think to your
point, there's a difference on
when those supports were
provided pre-pandemic. Okay, I
think that you have answered my
question but I really I
appreciate that we are not just
again, appreciate your work,
all of you and your briefings
and that you are giving us
details on not just doing the
band aids or the symptoms but
looking at some of the root
causes that are underneath. So,
I thank you for that. Okay
Thank you Trustee Doctor Jara.
Yeah, matter of vice president,
members of the board, I I think
Doctor Barden is being modest
but when you think about the
work that started under Doctor
Barden's leadership around
mental health and MTLL teams in
every school. The Council of
Great City Schools has really
highlighted that and shared
that across the country as the
leading effort. Um so there's a
lot of things that we continue
to learn from. I mean,
yesterday, I'd learned from
some of the work that San
Antonio is doing. Up in New
York city. So, there's a
constant learning curve that
we're doing with other
districts. Um so, just commend
Doctor Barton and his
leadership and the team because
it's something that has been
highlighted and shared with
others around some of this
work. Now, where we need to be
and a lot of work ahead. I also
like to point out, I mean,
community, we've done an RFB or
community partners. Um using SR
dollars that's out there and
that's something that will
continue. So, if there's other
community partners that want to
participate in helping our kids
get to school there's that
possibility for the coming
year. I know Chicago Public
Schools that they're doing a
lot of work with with the
churches to really do those
knocking on doors. Um so that's
that's going to be continue to
be out there and available for
community partners. So it's not
just the ones that we currently
have but there's others. Thank
you Doctor Jarham. I see
Trustee Brooks has a questions?
Thank you. I didn't really have
questions. Um I do appreciate
the information. I I want to be
honest about where we are as a
district and a community. I
don't expect us to reach these
goals. I think it would be I
think it'd be unreasonable
given the fact that we're at
the tail end hopefully with the
tail end of a pandemic Um
attendance obviously has not
been a priority this year.
People have struggled entering
quarantine and going back to
schools. So I want to be
realistic that I know that we
are not going to meet these
goals and I am going to be okay
with that because I recognize
that we have prioritized health
and and that's been universally
accepted. So, I think we have a
lot of work to do but I also
know that this isn't really
reflective of a normal
circumstance. So, I think it's
important to add that nuance
when you look at this
information and whether or not
this is something that we have
absolutely focused on and
prioritizing in my opinion we
haven't and I am okay with that
given the circumstances. Thank
you, Trustee Brooks. Trustees,
I'm going to take the liberty
to share my comments and then,
I see you in the queue. Thank
you. My comments are simply,
thank you for shining a light
on this multi-faceted issue
that exists in our school
district. Thank you for
continuing to listen to
students and you know, at the
same time, abiding by the
federal definitions of chronic
absenteeism that were you know,
have to uphold. Um thank you
for working with our incredible
partners, the county, the city,
the organizations who support
this work. Really my my comment
is more also in addition to to
sharing my gratitude to you and
the team Doctor Barton is maybe
would like to encourage my
colleagues to hear that there
is continued concern but
perhaps we would benefit from
evaluating in the near future.
Uh our legislative priorities
and find ways to address the
concerns that are that staff
have shared here. Um this could
be a place where we could all
collaborate. Trustee Cavazos.
Actually Vice President Garcia
Morales. I think that my
question is probably going to
be better suited to four oh
two. Having to do with safety
and kind of making a
connection. With the
absenteeism and school safety
say they want to hold off all
that. Thank you though. Very
good. Thank you so much. At
this time if there are no other
questions or comments, we're
going to move on to 4. 0 two.
4. oh two.
Thank you, gentlemen.
So we're transitioning a little
bit and bringing some team
members up. Doctor Massey, are
you solo? You're running solo?
Alright, man of the hour. 4. oh
two. moving on to 4. 02, which
is strategic plan update on
student safety. Doctor Mancy.
and vice president, members of
the board, Superintendent Jara,
for the record, Greg Manzi,
assistant superintendent of
assessment, accountability,
research, and school
improvement division. Before
you tonight is a presentation
aligned to the district's
strategic plan, focused 2024,
providing an update on the
indicator of student safety.
The indicator of student safety
contributes to the vision of
the Board of School Trustees
through the student's success
priority area specifically
under safety and engagement.
the student safety results were
previously presented in March
of twenty fifteen, October of
twenty sixteen, and May of
twenty nineteen. The May of
2019 presentation included
results of the district wide
survey overall. Um that was
presented during a board work
session.
What you'll see here, so the
measure of student safety
included in Focus 2024 is
derived from four questions
within the district wide survey
for students as shown on the
slide. It's important to note
that the first item responding
negatively is actually the
desired outcome. Therefore,
responses for this question are
reversed to calculate the
measure of student safety. The
district wide survey for
students is administered on an
annual basis typically in the
months of November and
December. The most recent
administration took place from
November 1st 2021 until
December 17th of 2021. The
district wides for students is
available in English and
Spanish. This is important as
the timing of the survey
administration and subsequent
reports aligns to the school
performance framework cycle as
well as data review event at
the beginning of the second
semester in January and
February. The current iteration
of the survey is in its sixth
consecutive year and was
developed during the twenty
fifteen, 2016 school year in
partnership with West Ed. The
questions are from a
combination of prior CCSD
iterations of the survey, the
City of Chicago Consortium on
School Research and the Nevada
Department of Education. The
full district wide survey
captures student perceptions in
a variety of areas including
parent involvement, learning
attitudes, social learning, and
perceptions of school
performance.
The purpose of the district
wide survey is to elicit
feedback on the climate,
culture, and school community,
informing our theory of action
that if we focus on
strengthening school
communities by implementing
multi-tiered system of supports
or MTSS, the students
perception of safety will
increase. The trustees may
recall that during December
9th, 2021, Regular Board
Meeting, the Board Approved
Policy sixty-one twenty-one,
Multi-tiered System of
Supports. Policy 61 2120
requires that all schools in
collaboration with stakeholders
implement the district wide
framework for multi-tiered
system of supports to ensure
all students receive equitable
access to opportunities to
promote each student's academic
achievement, social emotional
growth, and behavioral
development.
The district wide survey for
students is administered for
students in grades four through
grade twelve. The district
results for the perception of
safety are shown on this first
slide. A consistent trend that
will be observed across all
charts shown today includes the
increase in perception of
safety for the twenty twenty,
2021 results. Completed when
the district was implementing
distance learning. The 2021,
2022 results reveal a return to
rates closely aligned to the
percentages from prior to the
COVID-19 pandemic. With slight
increases observed across all
student groups when compared to
the twenty nineteen, 2020
results.
On the next slide, you'll find
results from the elementary
schools. For elementary
schools, the results includes
students in grade 4 and grade
five. The grades at elementary
are purposely selected to allow
for the highest degree of
independence and completion of
the survey. Therefore, more
reliable results. In the
elementary school results, we
observe that the increase
during distance learning was
not as drastic but surpassed
90% positive during that time
for the district and several
student groups. The results of
the twenty twenty-one, 2022
school year reveal percentage
positive responses slightly
higher across the majority of
student groups when compared to
the 2020 results.
On the third day to slide,
you'll see the results from
middle schools. For middle
schools, the results includes
students in grades six through
grade eight. In the middle
school results, we observe a
greater increase during the
twenty 20. 2021 school year
while in distance learning.
Nearly approaching 90% positive
for middle school overall. All
student groups also saw
increases in that same time
frame. Once again, the results
of the twenty twenty-one, 2022
school year revealed percentage
positive responses slightly
higher across most student
groups when compared to the
twenty nineteen, 2020 results.
On the final data slide, you
will find the results for high
schools. For high schools, the
results includes students in
grades nine through grade
twelve. In the high school
results, we observe a greater
increase during the 20 20. 2021
school year while in distance
learning across all student
groups. And we see a return in
school sites, we can observe
that the results of the twenty
twenty-one, 2022 school year
are slightly increased across
all student groups when
compared to the twenty
nineteen, 2020 results.
The district strategic plan
outlines the target percentage
of students who feel safe as
measured by the district wide
survey questions previously
outlined. The table on the
slide provides us with the
twenty twenty-one, 2022 target,
and actual results including an
indicator that the targets were
not met.
Limited context is available to
compare the district
performance to others. It is
important to note that
comparison rates were generated
based on similar questions but
no district asks identical
questions to ours. The results
from Los Angeles Unified
District were derived from one
question. I feel safe in this
school or an online school
sessions. When reviewing the
annual trend for Los Angeles
Unified District, we do observe
that their results were likely
influenced similarly to ours
during the twenty twenty, 2021
school year, while distance
learning. The results for
Washoe County School District,
Denver Public Schools, and
Miami Dade County Public
Schools are derived from a
singular question, all similar
to I feel safe at my school.
Results from Albuquerque Public
Schools and Houston Independent
School District were not
available for comparison. we
acknowledge the challenges,
successes, and lessons learned
as we reflect on the results.
We recognize that we
encountered a challenge as
students return to face-to-face
learning, reacclimating to
student school structures and
systems following a year of
distance learning. Within the
results, we also observe
success with an increase in
survey participation when
compared to the twenty twenty,
2021 results. We also observe
that the results aligned to the
pre-covid-19 results across all
grade vans with modest
improvement when compared to
the 1920 school year. As part
of a continuous improvement
process and reflection of the
results, we developed lessons,
learned, and a plan for
adjustments. The lesson learned
includes recognizing that
perceptions of safety increased
while in distance learning.
Our next steps are separated
into two slides. The first
slide is focused on our next
steps aligned specifically to
the district wide survey. The
results of the district wide
survey will be utilized by
continuous improvement teams as
they conduct the event called
Status Check eight as part of
the school performance plan
process. From May twenty
twenty-two to June 2022. In the
fall, school continuous
improvement teams will have an
opportunity to revise the
school performance plan to
incorporate action steps that
address the observations from
the district wide survey the
district wide survey will open
then in November of 20 22 and
remain open through December
2022 up until winter break. The
results of the survey
administered for the 22-23
school year will include an
analysis of additional
indicators such as panorama
results and student attendance.
The second focus of next steps
includes actions to increase
student safety. Most recently,
we communicated the emphasis of
the Clark County School
District Pre K through grade 12
Student Code of Conduct
including Apparently
Communication and Video Message
provided by the superintendent.
During the summer, region
leadership will provide
district wide multi-tiered
system of supports professional
learning for school site
leaders that includes
high-quality tier one,
academic, and behavioral
instruction and supports. By
August 20 22, Resources for
School Sites will be provided
including tier 1 safety
protocols, reengagement
procedures, and student
communication materials.
Thank you for your time. Thank
you Doctor Mensey. Are we, now,
are taking questions Excuse me,
thank you. I want to jump
straight into questions but I'm
grateful for Trustee Guzman who
reminds me of our public
comment. This time, we have
several members of the audience
who would like to speak on
public comment starting with
Adam Tampa, Anna Binder, Sarah
Conroe, and I'll announce a
couple of others in a minute.
Welcome back. Autumn Tampa,
speaking as an individual. I'm
first want to note that I did
the survey and I did not think
it was detailed enough or
specific enough or allowed for
enough comment for people to
give more information. It was
very very general and I don't,
you know. So, when you think of
safety, I think of physical
safety, as somebody going to
beat me up, is somebody
going to shoot me when I go to
the parking lot? Um, is a
student going to hurt me? If
I'm on a high school campus,
I've actually even been hurt by
elementary students when when
working. So, there's physical,
then, there's mental. Are the
people that I'm interacting
with, playing any kind of abuse
games verbally? Are they, you
know, undermining my
individuality? Are they giving
negative comments to me on a
daily basis? I know I once
observed a second-grade teacher
calling her children stupid on
a regular daily basis. To me,
that was mental unsafeness.
Then, you have unsafeness
where, you know, your emotions
are not validated where you're,
if you have a reaction that
you're not supposed to have,
then, it's, you know, your
shame on you and that's shaming
and that's emotional unsafety
and I think all of those
factors are critically
important and they're not being
looked at. Um I've been on many
many campuses over 160 and I
felt safe physically on most of
them. I did not feel mentally
or emotionally safe on too many
of them. And I know that
students and the whole culture
of discipline, the whole
culture of of fold your arms
and march like a soldier and
you better not move or you
better not turn the wrong way.
Don't look backwards. It's
absurd. They're children. They
are supposed to be moving.
They're supposed to be excited.
They're supposed to have
feelings. So, that whole
perspective needs to be fixed
from top down. It's wrong and
it's hurting people. Thank you,
miss Tampa. miss Binder still
present?
Uh in the meantime, Miss
Conroe, would you like to come
up I think I hear her but oh
there she is. Forgive me. We'll
go ahead Miss Binder. 4. oh
two. Awesome. Welcome back.
Thank you. Thank you, Madam
President. Members of board,
Doctor Jara. Um So, this
presentation Sorry, I'll pull
your page. Waste my time. I
don't care. Sorry, I could've
been more prepared on that one.
Four point, right? Point02.
There we go. So, focusing on
students' safety. We're still
getting a lot of reports from
parents in the community whose
kids are being adversely
punished for reporting bullying
and harassment and physical
contact that's being made to
them on our campuses. Um I'm
sure you guys hear a lot of
that from your community.
hopefully, in your respective
districts. What was really,
really fascinating to me
because I saw that you guys
referenced going back to some
surveys before COVID, and when
we were in shutdown and I was
yelling about student suicide
and things like that and
getting our schools back open.
Um I took a look at a survey
that students complete once a
year and I thought it was
interesting because I didn't
really know about this till I
found it and then I asked my
kids. I'm like, you guys really
take this every year? And
they're like, girl And in that
survey, they also, these kids
are also reporting they don't
have access to fresh fruits and
vegetables. These students are
like over forty, fifty, 60% at
risk of contracting STDs, being
sexually assaulted, becoming
pregnant. Um when we want to
talk about safety and we don't
have, you know, them feeling
safe kind of says that like,
oh, we're kind of getting back
to like pre-covid? That's a
nightmare to even think about.
So, Doctor Jara, you mentioned,
you know, for people who want
to help and all of this stuff,
I still have my NVLA, PTA
president, who hasn't been
approved for. Thank you, miss
Binder. Let's Miss Conroe, are
you available? And then we have
Ed Gonzalez and Camilla by
Waters.
Welcome back. Thank you very
much. Sarah Conroe for the
record and I think my last one
for the night. Um I I was
looking at the data and and
it's very possible that I
missed it because I was trying
to go through all the papers in
that giant stack but is this
survey given in students'
native language? For bilingual
and multilingual students. And
for our special education
students and our some of our
low level learners. Um is it to
them and I'm curious to know
what the wording in the
questions is. Because a lot of
the surveys that I have
received as a as a teacher ask
me a question and then I start
to answer and I'm like wait, is
it, was it that? Or is it that?
I'm not really sure. It feels
like I'm taking the ACT and
it's a trick question and I'm
like, am I going to get into
the college I want? Um, and
these are supposed to be like
very simple, straightforward
questions, but they become
complicated. And so, it makes
me question The accuracy of the
data. It also depends does, is
the student in secondary ed,
taking this survey when they
are, in a class with a teacher
they really like. Because in
that moment, they feel safe.
But maybe when they go to their
next period, kind of sketchy,
not so much. And so, I just, I
questioned the validity of the
data if we don't know all of
this back stuff, and maybe you
guys know, but I just feel like
that stuff that you might
want to think about when you're
looking at data. Thank you so
much. Thank you, Miss Conro Ed
Gonzales and then Camilla
Bywaters. Thank you, Ed.
Welcome. Come back.
Thank you madam. Vice
President. I actually did
leave. So, it is appropriate to
say welcome back. Um my name is
Ed Gonzales. I will actually
put on a hat not just a
physical one. Uh can you
remember Hickey Elementary
School Organizational Team? Um
the reason I'm commenting on
this item is that there was a
review that was sent to the
school organizational teens
about the code of conduct. Um
it was very vague. It just
asked to be reviewed. Um our
SOT did actually take a vote
and to ask the I believe this
would be under operationals for
the superintendent. Um one of
the things that are concerned,
I'll just read the motion. It's
very basic. Um the motion was
to send to the district that
the Hickey Elementary School
believe that any attack on a
staff member if successful or
not should be held to the same
standard and principles and
administrative teams should
have more say on student
discipline. Now, I understand
state law does not necessarily
allow for that. It is ironic
that the legislature when I
spoke earlier in public comment
gave more authority and
autonomy to principles and at
the same time, when it came to
discipline, they did the
complete opposite and made it
go back into Central. I
understand the hypocrisy of the
legislature at times. But the
main thing that our concern and
I will give you an example,
let's say I'm a and I throw a
chair at a teacher. The
difference in punishment on
this code of conduct is whether
that that chair hits the
teacher and injures them. So,
if the teacher is swift enough
to move out of the way, it's a
different level punishment.
Now, I understand that it
should be treated slightly
different but it should be held
at the same standard because
the intent was there. I'll give
you an a sports analogy. If you
attack an official, it's the
integrity of the game and you
usually are banned for life. I
am not suggesting that under
this policy but I'm suggesting
it should be held in the same
area level and within it, there
should be some, you know,
varying levels depending where
it is. That is what the Hickey
Elementary School team believes
because we are concerned that
staff members are being
attacked. Staff members are
getting hit and what's the
appropriate punishment? My
chair has come here before and
saying that all behavior is
learned and if they feel like
they can throw a chair and get
away with it, what's the next
student going to do? Thank you,
madam vice president. Thank
you, mister Gonzales by Waters.
Cami Bywaters, president of the
Las Vegas Alliance of Black
School Educators. I definitely
agree with the sentiments that
were made about the validity
and the reliability of the
survey. Um I think it would be
also important to maybe tweak
this a little bit and see look
at the result but also to
include an opportunity for
students to state why they feel
unsafe and what specifically
makes them feel unsafe in
schools. Um that that will
really be the only way that we
can target solutions when we
understand the specific
reasons. Um one of the big
issues that also impacts
students' safety is the lack of
appropriate and effective
response. When issues are
brought to school leaders,
there has to be an immediate
response to these issues. For
example, I just sent each of
you a letter about Desert Oasis
High School to parents had
complaints about some issues
there. Went to the school and
they did not feel that their
issues were addressed and fact,
their daughter, two daughters,
were expelled. And the
individuals who were causing
these situations were not
treated the same way. Um so it
really is important that
students safety issues from
families are addressed in a
timely fashion. So that
students don't take these
matters into their own hands
and also parents. So parents
don't take these matters into
their own hands. Um the parent
actually said to me I wish I
would have not gone to the
school and handled the
situation myself. But he
thought that to the school.
He'd be able to get some
solutions and nothing happened.
And I could see that this is a
problem that's happening
throughout our district. That
issues are not being handled.
Um consistently and in a timely
fashion. Thank you, miss Pie
Waters. At this time, I don't
see anymore public comments.
However, now we can move on to
Trustee Questions. Trustee
Williams, I see you in the
queue. Go ahead. Thank you,
madam vice president. Um Doctor
Mandy, I was. I guess I only
have like a question and a
comment but do you, when you
get these survey results, do
you go over this or review them
with the CCSDPD? Go ahead,
Doctor Mensey. Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, Superintendent Jara,
Trustee Williams. The results
specifically are not reviewed
with CCSDPD. We don't hold a
session or anything with them
for that availability. Can I
ask why? Doctor Jaroff? Doctor
Darrow, forgive me. I. Madam
Vice President, members of the
board, we do not but we do
review em in cabinet and Chief
Black I said to my cabinet. So,
when we review that, we as a
team, review so we can get to
address some of the issues and
kind of get into the next
steps. And Chief Black Guy sits
in my cabinet. Okay, thank you
Doctor Jar and then I guess my
only comment is on your slide.
Um slide five. I understand
this is the part of the MTSS
system that I think Doctor
Larson Mitchell had had briefed
to us. I want to say it was
last summer maybe. I don't
know. Quite sure. But on the
very end of that it says
increased perception of safety.
And while I understand there's
a perception of safety and
actuality of safety. I I get
worried or worrisome about the
the concept of like are we
working on actually making the
school safe as opposed to
letting that letting people
perceive that they're safe and
so that's just my only comment
to it. I think sometimes that
word gets thrown around and
people are like, oh, it must be
safe because it's perceived to
be safe and then, with every
student having a cellphone and
every single time, something
goes off, it's ends up on
Twitter or Instagram, whatever.
That's at the decreases the
perception that I, that would
be my only comment but thank
you so much for this. Thank
you, Trustee Williams. I see
Trustee Guzman is in the queue.
Go ahead. Thank you, vice
president. Um Mister Manzi,
there are couple of things that
I have questions about. First,
do you define safety for the
students in the survey? Doctor
Mancy. Madam Vice President,
members of the board,
Superintendent Jara, Trustee
Guzman, there is no definition
provided. It's about the the
students perception of that
word and that information as
they answer the question. So,
we're not telling them what
safety looks like. They're just
answering based on what they
know as safety. Yeah. Madam
vice president. Members of the
board. Yes. Okay. Okay. I just
wanted to make sure. And then
you did mention Doctor Manzi in
your when you were showing us
the slides that the survey was
in English and in Spanish. Is
that correct? Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, Superintendent Jara,
Trustee Guzman. Yes, that's
correct. Spanish and English
are the languages for the
survey. Great. And is the is
the survey read to our special
ed kids?
Madam President, members of the
board Um Superintendent Jara.
So, when students have those
reasonable accommodations that
are written in and they need
that support, that would be
provided for them by their
teacher. Okay. So, if it's
included in their IEP, then,
then, they would have it read
for them. Correct. Okay, great.
And then, my last question has
to be is about the time of year
that we choose to to do this
particular survey. Is there a
reason why we choose November
to December to do this type of
survey?
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jara, Trustee Guzman. So, the
time of year is really critical
for the survey. It gives us the
students some time in their
building to get their
perceptions and understanding
as well as align to the school
performance process and being
able to generate the results
and use it within the school
year to implement change for
the second semester. Thank you.
I appreciate that. Thank you,
Chelsea Guzman. I see Trustees
is in the queue and I will turn
your mic on. Thank you. Thank
Vice President Garcia and what
else? I just have one question.
Um Doctor Mancy and this is
kind of a this is what I asked
at the briefing but of course
the public doesn't see her
briefings and also to one of
our constituents brought it up
tonight too. And this has to do
with you know when they answer
the questions, you gave us the
exact questions. I believe that
how it's worded. So, that's the
literal language as used,
correct? So, I had asked during
the briefing but there isn't
any place where, you know, that
they can put an additional you
know, I do not feel safe. What
is the reason you don't feel
safe? You know, this is a
survey format, correct? Is
there anything that we're
looking at and again, at
appropriate grade level, you
know, like the elementary,
middle, and high school. Is
there anything we're looking
at? We're possibly that that
could be incorporated into
that. Even if it was just very
brief.
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jara, Trustees. So, we've other
tools that provide those that
avenue for a student, Safe
Voice being one of them where
they can type in that
information, provide that
comment which alerts
appropriate staff to be able to
take action at the school site
then. Thank you, Doctor Ansey.
So, we have those other which
I'm well aware of and which I'm
very happy that we do have but
what I'm saying is that there
isn't any connection between
that survey and the results of
that survey. It's not LA. Like
there's not like a follow up or
a connection to then these
other entities. Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, Superintendent Jara,
Trustees, they, the survey
serves a purpose of being able
to capture climate and
community and perception, that
is the intent of the survey,
not to do those additional
connections to them provide
intervention to a specific
student. Okay, so then the
other entities would be used
for the specific interventions,
and this is just more kind of a
global look at how they're
feeling. There isn't, you know,
basically there, checking it
off, and there isn't a place
for them putting in comments.
Thank you so much. I appreciate
Thank you, Josica Vazos,
Trustee Ford. Thank you. Um can
you explain a little bit the
questions and for instance, we,
I'm sorry, I think I lost my
thingy. Okay. So, we ask for
questions. I'm just kind of
repeating what we said. Four
questions on the survey. One of
them being reversed. Um the
four are I sometimes stay home
because I don't feel safe at
school. Students feel safe in
the school. The school has
safety procedures that work and
this school is safe. Um so
that's what we've been doing
and we've been doing it for
what like five or six years
something like that. 6 years.
Um and then and we're comparing
our responses of our survey to
all the other districts in that
chart which is great. Um but
how different are their
questions than our questions
Madam Vice President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jara, Trustee Ford, for the
other districts that are there,
we found that most of their
questions were a singular
question. Um I feel safe at
school being a common one that
was what we use to report the
comparison information. Ours is
the four questions that we've
outlined to kind of encapsulate
the student safety climate
overall. Okay, so here's my
comments which you've already
heard on my briefing. Um for
the record that out of all
these four questions, none of
them actually ask if that
individual student feels safe
at school. They in fact, they
could be interpreted. Like
students feel safe in school.
You know, maybe I'm a student
at a school and I don't feel
safe for whatever personal
reason and I'm thinking, noone
else feels this way. Like,
obviously, I'm only the only
one that feels unsafe in this
way. I look around and all my,
all the other students appear
to feel safe. I might check the
box of, yeah, students do feel
safe in this school. As far as
the school has safety
procedures that work, like it
was passed earlier, Could it be
interpreted like maybe that
student's not considering
things like, that they actually
fear, whatever that is, but
maybe they're looking around
and going, oh, it looks like
there's a operable check-in
system and nobody can really
get through the front door
without, you know, strangers
can't get in, but they're not
considering other safety
procedures, so, I guess I'm
just trying to say that I feel
like if we're going to compare
to other districts, that we
have be comparing the contents
of that metric and in the same
similar way. If we change it,
it would skew some of our data
and it would be, you know, we'd
be off a little bit in the six
years but it might be worth
looking at it. Can you can you
clarify one more time? Let's
say I'm a student. I take these
this four questions survey. How
many of these do I have to
mark? Positive For it to be
considered a positive result.
Madam Vice
President, members
of the board, Superintendent
Jara, Trustee Ford, it's an
aggregate measure. So, if the
student only answers three of
the four questions, we would
use the results from the three
questions to come up with the
total percent positive that's
presented before you here
today. Um so, we do look at
each individual question but
come up with an aggregate
number and that's what you're
seeing in the report. Okay. So,
if I was a student and I, you
know, say that I I don't stay
home because of my safety
fears. And I I say that the
students, most of the students
feel safe and I say, the
check-in system is working and
whatnot, even those three
things that would be a pretty
high result for, for me, but
nobody asked me if I actually,
personally feel safe, that's
just one of the things I think
we should consider, because I
do have, I brought it up at my
briefing, but I do have
questions about the validity of
the data, and while, I would
like to see improvement in
climate and culture and so, I
almost want to see results that
reflect what we're hearing and
what we're seeing from students
so that we could really know if
the changes that we're
implementing right now and
we're implementing a lot of
really positive changes. Are
actually making a dent in how
our students feel regarding
their safety at school. So, I
think it's a question worth
looking at and I'm okay for
now. Thank you. Chelsea Brooks.
Do you have any questions or
comments at this time? Thank
you Vice President Garcia
Morales. I have just been
listening to the comments.
There is a really good tool
that other board members can go
check out some comparison data
around the state. Um it's a
data tool dot Nevada School
Climate. org. Uh it actually
will let you look up this by
school. It'll look you look up
and compare it by the states
and other districts. So, I
would encourage us to start
looking at data like that. Um I
think the purpose of this
information being collected in
this manner is so that we can
compare it and if we start
talking about and critiquing
the questions and instead of
focusing on what it means, what
we're going to do about it and
how we're going to use it to
actually inform our decisions.
I think sometimes get a little
bit sidetracked. So, I would
encourage everybody to this
information up because I think
it's really important to have
that mindset. Uh I appreciate
the information. I know that
this year has been rough and I
don't have any questions. I
know that we have a lot of work
to do in regards to this
especially given the climate
and culture just in general and
I am committed to doing it with
staff. So, thank you. Thank
you, Trustee Brooks. I hear the
comments of my colleagues that
this continues to be a item
they want to continue to learn
more about and grateful that
this has come before today.
Thank you Doctor Mancy for your
time. Go ahead and move on to
item five point zero 1. Trustee
and Superintendent Business.
kind of 2021, 22 intuitive NRS,
statues, three eighty-eight A
dot two thirty-three, five-year
charter school site evaluation,
report and presentation. This
is a presentation, discussion,
and possible action regarding
the twenty-one twenty-two NRS
statues three eighty-eight A
point two two three. Five year
charter school site evaluation
report to submit to the
director of the Legislative
Council Bureau for transmittal
to the Legislative Committee on
Education as required by
Assembly Bill four sixty-two of
the eightieth session of the
Nevada Legislature. At this
time, Hello. Hi. Doctor Darth.
I think we're grateful to have
you here before us. Please go
ahead.
Madam President, esteemed board
members, superintendent Jara,
to be Superintendent Larson
Mitchell. For the record, Dan
Tafoya, Office of School
Choice. Thank you for allowing
me the opportunity to present
this evening. I will now refer
you to the slides on the
screen.
During the eightieth
legislative session, the
legislature revised statue
three eighty-eight, two two
three, which requires the
sponsor of a charter school to
conduct site evaluations for
each campus of a charter school
it sponsors during the first,
third, and fifth years after
entering or renewing a charter
contract. All of our six
sponsored charter schools are
currently in their fifth year
of a six year contract. The
CCSD office is school choice is
conducted site evaluations on
an annual basis for over the
past 10 years. Which includes a
thorough examination of the
academic, financial, An
operational components as per
the agreed upon charter
contract.
The statue requires three
components to be examined.
First, evaluation of pupil
achievement and student
performance at each campus. Our
office evaluates schools by
using metrics and measures
which are based upon the board
approved charter school
sponsorship guide, the Nevada
Performance Framework, Nevada
Revised Statute and Regulations
and other documents. Second,
identify any deficiencies
relating to pupil achievement
and school performance.
Identification of deficiencies
regarding the areas of
academic, financial, and
operational performance are
discovered through annual site
evaluations and audits. Site
evalu are conducted with
respect to school autonomy and
the agreed upon charter
contract. Third, plans to
correct such deficiencies.
Additionally, charter schools
have various support teams.
charter schools have various
support teams from and with in
collaboration with CCSD in an
effort to correct any areas of
deficiencies that are
discovered with a common goal
of improving student
achievement and overall student
performance.
I will now briefly update the
board on each school. First,
the 100 academy. The 100
Academy School of Engineering
and Technology was found to
have deficiencies in the
academic, financial, and
organizational components per
degreed upon CCSD charter
school performance framework
during the 2017, 2018, 2018,
2019, 2019, 2020, and the 2021
school years. As for academic
performance, due to the
school's academic performance
during the 2017, 2018 school
year, the Board of School Trus
voted in 2019 to reconstitute
the governing body of the 100
academy per NRS three
eighty-eight A 3 30. The
reconstitution stipulated that
the school would improve its
academic performance during the
remainder of the charter
contract. In 2018 20 19, the
school did improve its
elementary performance from one
star to a two-star rating on
the Nevada school performance
framework. The middle school
program remained a two-star
school but had improved in the
area of growth on the NSPF in
both mathematics and English
language arts. This effort
improved the NSPF score by five
point eight points. In
accordance with the US
Department of Education,
Elementary and Secondary
Education Act ESEA the ESEA
waiver. NDE suspended the
accountability requirements for
the 20 nineteen and the
20202021 school years in
response to the COVID pandemic.
The NSPF school ratings and
accountability indicators were
carried over from the 2018
-2019 reporting year. Therefore
the school has not had the
opportunity to provide academic
performance results. Regarding
the regarding the twenty twenty
one in 2022 school year, NDE
has not released the final NSPF
measurements when NDE
reinstates NSPF accountability
measurements, the school will
evaluate the academic
performance of the school. And
this goes for all the schools
we're going to discuss tonight.
They were all exempt from the
NSPF during those time periods
I discussed. The financial
performance at 100 Academy. The
100 academy was found to have
deficiencies in the financial
performance. Each year of the
current charter contract the
school has issued a notice of
concern or a notice of breach
for the Charter School
sponsorship guide and charter
contract. Each of the
deficiencies have been
addressed by the charter
school. Organizational, 100
academy was found to have
deficiencies in the
organizational performance each
year of the charter contract.
The school was issued a notice
of concern or a notice of
breach for the charter school
sponsorship guide and charter
contract. Each of the
deficiencies have been
addressed by the charter
schools. By the charter school.
Thank you. Slide
The Delta Academy. The Delta
Academy was found to have
deficiencies in the academic,
financial, and organizational
components per degree upon
contract and charter school
performance framework during
the 2017, 2018, 2018, 2019,
2019, and twenty twenty, and
the twenty, 2021 school years.
Academic performance, due to
the school's academic
performance during the 2017,
2018 school year, the Board of
School Trustees voted in 20 19,
to reconstitute the Delta
Academy's governing body, per
NRS three eight eight A, 330.
The reconstitution stipulated
the school would improve its
academic performance remainder
of the charter contract. In
2018, 2019, the school did
improve its middle school
performance from a one one star
to a two-star rating on the
NSPF. In 2020, the high school
applied for and was granted
placement on the Nevada
Department of Education's
Alternative Performance
Framework. Again, NDE carried
the previous NSPF scores over
to the COVID overdue to the
COVID-19 pandemic. When NDE
reinstates the NSPF and APF
accountability measures, the
school will be evaluated for
their performance based on
those measures. Financial
performance, the Delta Academy
was found to have deficiencies
in their financial performance
in the twenty nineteen, 2020,
and the 2021 school years. The
school was issued a notice of
concern and a notice of breach
for the Charter School
sponsorship guide and the
charter contract. The Delta the
Delta Academy governing body
has submitted a corrective
action plan and continues to
address financial deficiencies.
Organizational performance. The
Delta Academy was found to have
deficiencies in the
organizational performance with
the twenty nineteen, 2020 and
the 20 2021 school years. The
school has issued a notice of
concern and a notice of breach
for the charter school
sponsorship guide and the
charter contract, the Delta
Academy Governing Body has
submitted a corrective action
plan and continues to address
these deficiencies.
Next slide is explore knowledge
academy. The Explore Knowledge
Academy was found to have
deficiencies in the academic
component where they agreed
upon CCSD charter school
performance framework during
the 2017 and 2018 school year.
Due to the school's academic
performance in the middle
school during the 2017 and 2018
school year, the Explorer
Knowledge Academy was issued a
notice concern for the charter
school sponsorship guide and
the charter contract in the
2018 -20 19 school year, the
school did improve its academic
performance in the middle
school from a two star to a
three-star rating on the NSPF.
Again, their scores were
carried over due to the COVID
pandemic. Financial
performance, for all years, of
the charter contract, there
were no financial deficiencies
to report, organizational, for
all years of the current
charter contract, explore
knowledge had no organizational
deficiencies to report.
Innovations International,
Charter School of Nevada,
Innovations International
Charter School was found to
have deficiencies in the
academic, financial, and
organizational components for
the agreed upon CCSD Charter
School Performance Framework.
During the 2017, 2018, 2018,
2019, 2019, and twenty twenty,
and the 20 2021 school years.
Academic performance, due to
the school's academic
performance in 20 17, 2018
school year, the innovation
system national charter school
in Nevada was issued a notice
of concern for the charter
school sponsor guide, and
charter contract in the twenty
eighteen, 2019 school year, the
school did improve its academic
performance from a two-star to
a three-star on the NSPF at all
grade levels, K through twelve.
I should say testable grade
levels. Financial performance,
international innovations
international charter school in
Nevada was found to have
deficiencies in their financial
performance. Each year, the
current charter contract. The
school has issued a notice of
concern or a notice of breach
for the charter school
sponsorship guide and the
charter school contract. Each
of the deficiencies have been
addressed by the charter
school. Organizational
performance, innovations such
as international charter school
was found to have deficiencies
in their organizational
performance for the 20
nineteen, 2020, 2020, 2021
school years, the school has
issued a notice concern and a
notice of breach per the
charter school sponsorship
guide and the charter school
contract, each of the
deficiencies have has been
sufficiently addressed by the
charter school.
Odyssey Charter School, Odyssey
Charter School is found to have
deficiencies in the academic
component per the agreed upon
CCSD charter school performance
framework during the 2017, 2018
school year. Due to the
school's academic performance,
the elementary and high school
during the 2017, 2018 school
year, Odyssey Charter School
was issued a notice of concern
for the Charter School
sponsorship guide in the
charter contract. In the twenty
eighteen, 2019 school year, the
school did improve its academic
performance from a two-star to
a four-star rating in the
elementary school and from a
two-star to a three-star rating
in the high school. On the
Nevada NSPF. Again, their
scores were overdue the COVID
pandemic. Financial performance
for all years of the charter
contract. There were no
financial deficiencies to
report. Organization
performance for all years of
the charter contract there were
no organizational deficiencies
to report as well.
The Rainbow Dreams Early
Learning Academy was found to
have deficiencies in the
academic, financial, and
organizational components for
their greed upon CCSD charter
school performance framework.
During the 2017, 2018, 2018,
2019, 2019, 2020, and the
twenty20 2021 school years. Due
to the school's academic
performance during the 2017,
2018 school year, the Board of
Trustees in 2019, placed the
school on a mandated
remediation plan. The plan
stipulated that they would
improve their academic
performance during the
remainder of the charter
contract. In 2020, Dream's
Early Learning Academy
requested to eliminate services
to grade to grades one through
eight and to change the mission
of the Rainbow Dreams Early
Learning Academy Charter School
to only serve pre-kindergarten
and kindergarten students on
their campus on June 11th,
2020. The CCSD Board of
Trustees approved the request
for the school to serve pre K
and kindergarten only. The
school will use and has used
industry standard evaluation
tools such as Brigans and My
Standards Golds to measure
students and achievement since
they are no longer being rated
on the NSPF. As for financial
performance, for the for the
2017, 2018, to the 2019, 2020
school year, all financial
performance deficiencies have
been addressed. As for the 2021
school year, Rainbow Dreams
Early Learning Academy was
issued a notice of breach by
CCSD. The notice of breach
identified a financial
deficiency. Which was based
upon the school owing an
outstanding debt to the Nevada
Department of Education. At the
time of this report was
published, Rainbow Dreams Early
Learn Academy had not
sufficiently addressed the
performance deficiency. I am
pleased to report to this board
this evening that the school
has paid its debt in full to
the Nevada Department of
Education and and has
sufficiently addressed the
financial deficiencies to the
satisfaction of the sponsor.
All financial performance
deficiencies as of now have
been addressed. Organizational
performance, Rainbow Dreams
Early Learning Academy was
found to have deficiencies in
their organizational
performance for the twenty
nineteen, 2020, and the 2021
school year. The school has
issued a notice of concern for
the charter school sponsorship
guide and the charter contract.
Each of the deficiencies have
been addressed sufficiently by
the school. The same board,
superintendents, That concludes
my report. Thank you, mister
Tafoya for your presentation.
At this time, I'd like to take
public comment.
We do not 5. 01. we have Miss
Camilla Bywaters 5 point 0 1.
it. A Miss Binder
And it meant to wink at you
that way just to we've got you.
We've got you Miss Binder.
Welcome back. Hey, Camilla
Bywaters, president of the Las
Vegas Alliance of Black School
Educators. So, I think
Principal Henry deserves a hand
clap here for that increase of
standards. That's not easy to
do. Um after four years of
having to bring a school to a
new standard. One thing I would
like to address though, Rainbow
Dreams is a a black-owned
school. I could not after I I
learned about the kind of
pressing and bill collecting
that was going on. Um it seemed
that there was not really any
grace in the matter. And in
collecting and turning in the
fees to whoever these fees need
to be turned into. So I'm glad
to know that it was stated
today that the school is debt
free and has paid back what
they have owed. Um but it is
one it is kind of concerning to
me that there was such a
pressing and
close to
stressful for a school in eight
nine, one, oh six, to be given
such a pressure to pay their
bill which there was never a
problem with paying the bill.
Um so I would I think it's
really important that we do
what we can to support our
schools that support our
minoritized communities
especially early early learning
schools. Um there's not too
many opportunities for our
black and brown babies to
attend schools that provide
it's a great great service. So
I do think that it's very
commendable that Miss Henry has
been able to get a staff that
is phenomenal at Rainbow
Dreams. My daughter attends
Rainbow Dreams. She knows her
ABC. She knows how to write her
name. And she knows how to come
to the school board meeting and
cut up a little bit. So I do
just want to make sure that
there's a recognition of the
work that she has done to have
a good report here. Thank you
Miss Bywaters. Miss Binder.
Thank you. So, I actually was
going to hit that because at
the state level, there's many,
many conversations going on in
the early learning category and
trying to increase services to
our communities because early
education is one of the most
amazing things that we can give
our children. So, but miss
Bywaters was here tonight. So,
she kind of hit the rest on the
head but there's great strides
at the state level being made
for the investments into more
support in our community. Um
for early education and I
believe they're getting ready
to do a round table I think in
the next quarter to bring
people in the community and for
better ideas in zip codes that
are typically left out of those
conversations. So, thanks.
Thank you, miss Bender. Doctor
Jara. Yeah, madam president
members of the minor vice
president members of the board.
I just need to correct the
record because this staff has
intimately worked with
Congressman Horsworth, with the
State Department, who addressed
the needs, and the county.
Commissioner Kirkpatrick worked
with us to provide the support
for for Rainbow Dreams and
really working closely as we
went through the payment plans.
I just needed to correct the
record in our grace and
supporting the unity. Um
Congressman Horfords has been
in close contact with Doctor
Bartenbaugh and myself to make
sure that children are served
this community. Thank you.
Thank you for your support,
Doctor Jaro. At this time, I'd
like to turn it over to my
colleagues. because we're ready
for questions, and I don't see
anybody in the queue right now.
Perhaps, Trustee Brooks, Jessie
Brooks doesn't have any
questions, I would like to put
myself in the queue? I have any
questions. Thank you. Thank
you, Trissy Brooks. My
question, could you provide us,
provide us insight on how we
came into overseeing charter
schools?
Steam Trustees, Superintendent
and staff, thank you for that
question. In the 1990 19 99
legislature, there was a bill
passed that allowed people such
as or entities such as school
districts and the state to
sponsor charter schools. So, it
was a law that was enacted and
a matter of fact, we have one
of the oldest charter schools
that was part of that law
that's Odyssey Charter School.
It's been around now 22 years.
So, it was an through that law
and the school district at that
time started open charter
schools. Uh the state did as
well. And at this time, we have
a state charter authority that
oversees specific charter
schools. There always has been
some authority. Right? At the
state level. Um so
I just want to verify and
confirm that that's the case.
Is that right? Trustees,
superintendent staff for the
record Dan Tafoya. Uh that is
correct. At one time, it was
the Nevada Department of
Education through a legislative
act. There was the formation of
the Charter School Authority
which does see oversee other
charter school portfolios
throughout the state. Uh the
Washoe County School District
also sees a portfolio of
schools such as Clark County
and Carson City. I believe sees
one of those schools as well.
Thank you, mister Defoya,
Doctor Jarro. Yes, madam Madam
Vice President, members of the
board. There's also provision
within the charter law of if if
at any time in the Mister of
can speak to that. Um where the
school board can then transfer
back charter schools into
current charter schools that we
authorize instead supervise and
transfer them to the state
charter authority as well. So
there is there is a provision
within a statue to do that for
that to happen as well. Doctor
Darrer, does that happen?
Mister Defoy, does that happen
at any time? Or is that a Can
that happen anytime or does it
have to happen at specific time
of the year? No, I mean, I
think it's a it's a
conversation that we would have
to have with the state charter
authority. Obviously, the main
and priority is to make sure
that when that happens, it's
aligned to a school year and to
make sure that our the children
are are served. Um so, I think
it's it's if it's something
that there's an interest that
we can start having
conversations with the state
charter authority to do that.
Thank you, Doctor Dara. My the
reason I asked about history
and and the insight is because
as I'm seeing, I'm grateful for
the progress that's taken place
in some of the charter schools
that we really have that have
been presented here today Um
and hearing some other
challenges and hardships that
some real challenges and
hardships that some of our
students face in often times
and and the neediest community.
I I wonder whether we are the
right unit to be supporting our
charter schools. I mean, it's a
really hard conversation to
have because You know, we have
been supporting them and it
sounds like we're on a
five-year agreement, five-year
agreement, is that what I
heard? Six-year agreement,
five-year of a six-year but it,
I, I would like to have that
discussion at some point and I,
you know, this presentation is
a glaring reminder that we we
should have it. Doctor Jarroff.
Um Madam Vice President,
members of the board, we can
start having the internal
conversations with staff to
start looking at it and to see
what the potential obviously
for us. Um and for the Charter
Authority and and for you as
well is making sure that we
take care of our children. Um
and what that looks like. Um so
we can then look at it and see
what the timelines and then we
can bring something back to
this board. Thank you Doctor
Jarrod. I'm going to Go back I
appreciate those those answers.
I'm going to I see that Trustee
Ford has a question or like to
be in the queue. Go ahead
Trustee Ford. Thank you so
much. Um couple questions. Um
first you know, there's all
different types of charters,
charter schools, including
online schools that would run
much differently than
traditional brick-and-mortar
schools. Are all of the charter
schools that we are sponsoring?
Are they all traditional style
students in the seat type of
schools or are there any type
of alternate versions of
education? For the record,
Esteem Board, Superintendent
and staff, Dantefoy for the
record. Uh we do have Odyssey
Charter School which is a
hybrid school where children
return attend online part of
the week and their in-person
part time. We also have Delta
Academy which is a school that
is as you as I mentioned
earlier is under the APF. They
do have students that attend
online and full time and some
students who in who attend in
between as well. Other schools
are traditional schools that
are brick and mortar face to
face type schools. Thank you Um
so the the purpose of this was
really to compare you know,
using the same standards, how
successful a charter school
would be as a public school. I
guess I'm just trying to
knowing that two of them look
different than most of our
schools, I guess, except for oh
my god we can't think of it.
Learning academy. Um how
similar are these schools to
CCSD? Like are we seeing, is it
comparable sizes? Is it are we
seeing the same rates of
absenteeism? Do they like, do
we have any of that
information? For the record of
Steam Board, Superintendent and
Staff, Dantefoy for the record.
So, the charter schools are
mandated under many of the same
NDE regulations as regular
school districts would be. So,
a lot of the class sizes are
comparable. Absenteeism rates
are pretty much as you would
see in the district. Some
schools you see, they have
comparative absenteeism rate.
Other schools you see that
maybe it is a higher
absenteeism rate than the than
the school that's surrounded by
And in some case as you see the
absentee risen absenteeism rate
lower than the local public
school that the the student may
attend. Thank you. Um so I
guess I'm trying to figure out
go for public CCSD schools. We
we have you know it doesn't
matter how many kids there are
versus how many teachers or
space there is. We're going to
take all students and all
behavior levels and all needs
of different students. So I
guess knowing that some of our
might be short on staff and
several classes combined into
larger areas like the cafeteria
and the gym and things and
dealing with some things that
arise from there like violence
and what not. Is that something
that they do as well or is
there some sort of cap on class
sizes or attendance or is it
just I guess how different is
that than our schools? Trustee
Ford for the record. Um Dan
Tafoya. There are a lot of
similarities. Uh you know,
after the pandemic, a lot of
our schools have faced exactly
the same issues that we faced
as well. Uh I can't point to
specifics as to exact
comparison or data studies but
I think that there's been a
shortage of employees. There's
been a shortage of the ability
for parents to send their their
kids to school. I think they
face many of the same issues
that we face as well. Uh there
are caps such as there are
mandated by ND for the state
for the Clark County School
District there are the similar
caps for them and so what we
have to do is monitor that to
see where they are. Um it is it
is very comparable to what you
are are describing. I think all
schools not only in Nevada but
nationwide are affected by many
of the same problems. Thank
you. Um do is transportation
provided to these schools?
Trustee board board
superintendent staff for the
record schools do have the
ability to provide
transportation. None of the
sponsored charter schools in
our portfolio do. I'm not aware
of any in the state at this
point. that do. That's a very
expensive endeavor. They can,
they can partner with this
school district to be able to
do that type of partnership
where there could be some
transportation but of course,
it would come at a cost and
charter schools with their
budget typically they don't
have the ability to provide
transportation. The other thing
is that they pull from multiple
zip codes. So, it would be a
big undertaking for them to be
able to have charter schools
provide transportation. I think
it would it be fair to say that
to attend one of these charter
schools that would the parents
would pretty much have to be
able to handle transportation
to and from school. Trustee
Ford seemed board,
superintendent staff for the
record Dan Tafoya. Uh it it
would be a a very fair
statement that parents do have
to provide that transportation
for their students. And they
have done so since I've been
here. Thank you. Um I I want
all schools to succeed. I you
know I Obviously, if kids are
happy at their schools, we hope
that they can meet the
standards. I just want to of
course, always look at the data
in a way that if we're
comparing against each other
that it is fair and accurate, I
would, I would just hate to
like compare on unfair metrics
and then, make the claim that
charters are more effective
than CCSD schools and then, you
know, lose funding to more
charters while at the same
time, I do want to support, you
know, different options of
schools and innovation and you
know, responses to the
community's desired schools and
whatnot. Um but my question, my
last question is, well, first,
I think it's great that the
ones that we've been overseeing
have made the successes that
they have and I really like the
change of Rainbow Dreams. Um I
think it's awesome but now that
we're in the fifth of the sixth
year, what happens next if for
say a couple of them are not
meeting the standards in the
future. What would the next
step be?
Trustee Ford Steam Board,
Superman and staff for the
record Dan Tafoya. Uh so as we
start to approach the end of
the contract, we would look at
the data that we have. Uh we
have the data that you see in
front of us. And where you see
that it may say falls below the
standard or doesn't meet the
standard is because at the time
of audit, the school may have
had a a deficiency. They may
have had a write up. They may
have been missing something in
a special folder. These are
very stringent type audits. So,
it only takes one thing for you
to not meet a standard audit.
You can come back and correct
that and bring it back into
alignment but we're not
going to change the rating. It
was the way it was when we
found it and we do that for
transparency sake. So, it would
be very easy. So, why I fixed
it? Let's turn it into green
and then, all I would show you
is green but the truth of the
matter through the through the
process of audit and
transparency when we when we
inspect those schools, what we
find is what we report. We do
give them the opportunity for
the NRS to make those
corrections and if they make
those corrections, then, they
are allowed to continue to
operate. If a school was not to
make one of those corrections,
then we would come back to this
board. We would issue the
proper legal documents to the
school if they still refuse. We
would come up. We would bring
them back to the board for the
board to consider either a
sanction or or a revocation of
that charter So, in the fact
that you may see that there's
red and that there's yellow, it
means at that time, that did
not meet the standard but we
bring em back to the board if
they did not, if they chose not
to make that standard for some
reason, say they went bankrupt,
then, you would, we'd be in
front of you with a bankruptcy
issue. Okay. Okay, interesting
question. Thank you so much.
Trustee Williams. Thank you,
Madam Vice President. Mister
Tafoya, thank you for your
comprehensive report. I try to
take a lot of that in, right?
As you're saying, but you speak
very fast. So, I just want to
say thank you and then, my only
question is with Rainbow Dreams
last year being their first
year doing pre K and again,
only, right? Um so then that
that report will be five more
years or is that where you guys
are just basing your data off
of just the one or year, two
year, every year, you guys are
just relooking at that?
Trustee Williams, the Steam
Board, Superintendent Staff for
the Record, Dan Tafoya. So,
annually, we monitor, we have
different departments that
monitor the progress that they
make in those areas and we
compare and we make those
comparison data. Uh this is
their first year so we don't
have any comparison data yet.
Sure. Uh but we will bring that
back to the board the next time
that we do have that data so
they can see where the students
have moved from point A to
point B and see if that is
sufficient in those lower grade
levels pre K and K there are
measurements out there that I
think that statistically could
be significant as far as
monitoring and providing a
description of how the school
is performing. Wonderful. Thank
you so much. I'm very big fan
of charter schools and
secondary education schools for
students in our district. So, I
think that's great. Um I don't
know if I need to make a motion
but I'd like to make a motion
just to accept the report and
move on to our next item but
thank you so much mister
Tafoya. Thank you for that
motion, Trustee Williams. Do we
have a second? So Trustee
Guzman in the queue. I'll
second. Thank you. We have a
motion for Trustee Williams and
a second by Trustee Guzman.
Trustees, please cast your
vote. Trustee Brooks.
The motion passes. Six to one
noting. Trustee is absent. Six
to zero. Why do I keep saying
one? She's here in spirit. Miss
you. President Zabeda. Alright.
Um thank you very much Mister
Tafoya for your time. I think
we are ready. To move on to 5.
02. Opening of sealed bids.
Call for oral bids and
resolution of acceptance of
bids offer to sell real
property site. Number zero 64.
02 dash two point that is two
point five acres of the
southeast corner of Rancho
Destino Road and East Reyes
Avenue, Frias Avenue.
Discussion and possible action
on the opening of seal bids
calling for oral bids accepting
the highest bid and accepting
adopting a resolution declaring
the highest bid to sell to sell
a 2. 5-acre parcel located on
the southeast corner of Rancho
Casino Road and East I just
repeated that same thing. one
seven seven two dash two eight
dash four zero one dash zero
zero six and for the
superintendent of Clark County
School Districts and the
president and the clerk of the
Board of Trustees Clark County
School District to sign the
resolution of acceptance bid is
recommended. I see the conduct
person as mister Campbell and
forgive me. Um Trustees, did we
seek public comment first
before the last time we did
this public comment first
before we open the seal bids? I
don't think so. No? Okay. Uh
there is isn't there a No? No.
No. Okay. Nope. Just kidding. I
want to be proactive. Thank
you. Uh
Trustee Guzman, I appreciate.
You're ready with the envelope?
Ready, ready. Okay, I need to
read these instructions. Would
you mind opening the envelope,
please? Thank you.
We're going to open the bid and
read out loud each bid amount
and the same and the name of
the submitter Go ahead. Go
ahead, Trustee Guzman. I'm
going to turn on your mic so we
can maybe tag team this. Are
you willing to do that? Yeah,
sure. Okay. Thank you. Um it
says the under signed Saint
Charbo Maronite Catholic
Mission Las Vegas Real Estate
Trust having carefully examined
the resolution of intent to
sell real estate property and
notice inviting bids adopted by
the Board of School Trustees of
the Clark County School
District on April 7 2 thousand
22 hereby submits a bid in the
total amount of five 000 for
the Southeast corner of Rancho
Destino Road and East Frias
Avenue, Las Vegas, Nevada eight
nine one eight three, assessor
parcel number 177 dash two
eight dash four zero one dash
zero zero six for a total of 2.
5 acres, the north West quarter
of the northeast quarter of the
southeast quarter of the
southwest quarter of section 28
Township twenty-two South Range
sixty-1 east MDB and M being
further described as government
lot 10four.
Excellent work. Trustee Guzman,
thank you for that. At this
time, are there any oral bids?
Can I say that going once?
Going twice? Yeah, we, we get
the gavel, are we good to, yes,
I think we, the oral okay so
there is no oral so we have one
bid and it it appears that we
we will accept that bid Um so
at this point I'm closing the
auction. And at this point I'd
like to request can you please
say the amount again Trustee
Guzman? Sure it's five hundred
and 000. Okay thank you very
much. At this time I'd like to
ask for a motion. I have it.
Thank you Jose Guzman
I motion for item 5. zero two
open opening of sealed bids
called for oral bids and
resolution of acceptance of bid
offer to sell real property sit
number zero six 02 dash 2. five
acres at the southwest corner
of Rancho Destino Road and East
Frias Avenue Thank you very
much for that motion. IC
Trustee Williams in you. I will
second that motion. Can you
identify the price and the
bidder? That's the second
motion. I had to motion for us
to actually open the bid. Okay.
That'll. Okay. Thank you,
council. Okay, at this time, we
have a motion by Trustee Guzman
and a motion by Missy Williams.
Excuse me, a second by Trustee
Williams. Uh this time,
Trustees, please cast your
vote. Jesse Brooks. Hi. That
motions passes six to zero.
Thank you so much Trustees.
Okay. At this point. At least
now I can do the motion to
accept the highest bid. Okay.
Thank you Trustee Guzman. Yes.
Go ahead. Okay. I motion to
accept the highest bid in the
amount of $530, 000 made by
Saint Charbo Maronite Catholic
Mission. Las Vegas Real Estate
Trust for the purchase of the
2. five zero acre parcel
located at the southeast corner
of Rancho Destino and East
Frius Avenue. Thank you, Josie
Guzman. I see Trustee Williams
is in the queue. I will second.
Thank you, Trusty Williams. A
motion by Trustee Guzman, a
second by Trustee Williams.
Trustees, please cast your
vote. Trustee Brooks. Hi. Okay,
that motion passes six to zero.
Noting justice is missing. As
not present today. I am missing
her. Um thank you so much
gentlemen for your time.
Congratulations.
No no fancy. No fancy math
footwork. Congratulations to
the to the winning bidder. Uh
Trustee Guzman, please share
congratulatory notes. Yes.
Congratulations to Saint
Charborough Maronite Catholic
Mission, Las Vegas Real Estate
Trust. Good luck. Excellent.
Thank you so much. At this.
point in time, we'd love to
move on to 5. 03. Public
hearing and possible approval
of the new memorandum of
agreement between the Clark
County School District and the
Clark County Association of
School Administrators and
Professional employees
regarding article 16 dash nine.
This is the time and place to
conduct a public hearing on a
discussion of and possible
action on approval of the new
memorandum agreement between
the Clark County School
District and the Clark County
Association of School
Administrators and Professional
Technical Employees. Um those
who wish to address the board
in person at the meeting may
speak may sign up to speak by
calling the board office. This
is all details that are moot
point. So this is the time and
place to conduct a public
hearing on discussion of and
possible action of approval of
the new memorandum of agreement
between CCSD and the Clark
County Association of School
Administrators and Professional
Technical Employees regarding
article sixteen nine.
Thank
you Madam Vice President,
Members of the Board of
Trustees, Doctor Jara. Uh my
name is David Hall, chief
negotiator and assistant
general council. Nevada revised
statute two eighty-eight point
one five three requires that
any new, extended, or modified
collective bargaining agreement
between a local government
employer and an employee
organization be approved by the
governing body of the local
government. Excuse me. the
local government employer and
an employer organization be
approved by the governing body,
the local government employer
at a public hearing and that
the chief executive officer of
the local government shall
report to the local government
the fiscal impact of the
agreement. The Board of
Trustees of the Clark County
School District or CCSD are
proved a negotiated agreement
with the Clark County
Association of School
Administrators and Professional
Technical Employees. Hereafter
to be referred to as Kasapi on
October twenty-eight 20 21, an
agreement has been reached
pending approval by the Board
of Trustees and the
Superintendent of Schools
regarding the new memorandum of
agreement between CCSD and
Kasapi regarding article 16
dash nine regarding the
executive manager and
superintendent's office. Kasapi
and CCSD drafted a new
memorandum of agreement to
modify the contract language in
article 16 dash nine to the
current effective day of July
1st, 2019 to December 1st, 20
21, The terms of this agreement
will be effective the date of
approval and signature. Any
additional cost associated with
entering into this memorandum
of agreement are diminimus.
This is the time place to
conduct a public hearing on
discussion of and possible
action on approval of the new
memorandum of agreement between
Clark County School District
and the Clark County
Association of School
Administrators and Professional
Technical Employees regarding
Article 16 dash nine. Thank you
mister Hall. I don't sweep see
any public comment on item five
point oh three. But this time
the public hearing is now
closed.
I'm looking for a motion to
close the public hearing
Trustee Williams. I motion to
close this public hearing.
Thank you, Trustee Williams.
Chelsea Brooks, would you like
to make a motion? Trustee
Guzman, you saved by Trustee
Guzman. I'll second. Thank you
very much. We have a motion by
Trustee Williams, a second by
Trustee Guzman. Trustees booth
class are both votes. Josie
Brooks. Hi. Thank you,
Trustees. That motion passes
passes six to zero. Close the
public hearing, noting Trustee
Sepeda is absent. At this point
in time, we're going to move on
to 5. 04. The public hearing
and possible action of approval
of the new memorandum of
agreement between Clark County
School District and the Clark
County Association. The school
administrators and professional
technical employees regarding
the 11 month school 11 months
school principals. This is a
time and place to conduct a
public hearing on discussion of
and possible action of the
approval. The new memorandum of
between Clark County School
District and the Clark County
Association School
Administrators and Professional
Technical Employees regarding
11 month school principals. We
Mister Hall. Thank you. Madam
Vice President, Members of the
board. Doctor Jara. My name is
David Hall for the record.
Chief negotiator and assistant
general council. Nevada Revi
statute two eighty-eight point
one five three requires it any
new, extended, or modified
collective bargaining agreement
between a local government
employer and an employee
organization be approved by the
governing body of the local
government, employer at a
public hearing, and that the
chief executive officer or the
local government for the local
government shall report to the
local government the fiscal
impact of the agreement. The
Board of Trustees of the Clark
County School District here and
after CCSD approved in a
negotiated agreement with the
Clark County Association of
School Administrators and
Professional Technical
Employees hereafter Kasapi on
October 28th 2021. An agreement
has been reached pending
approval by the Board of
Trustees and the superintendent
of schools regarding the new
memorandum of agreement between
CCSD and Kasapi. Regarding 11
month school principles. Kasapi
and CCSD drafted a new
memorandum of agreement to
modify the contract language in
article 16 dash to change all
current 11 month contracts for
school principals to 12 month
contracts with an effective
date of July 1st 2022. The
terms of this new agreement
will be effective the date of
approval and signature. The
fiscal impact of the memorandum
of agreement is approximately
$4. 1 million dollars. This is
the time and place to conduct
public hearing on discussion of
an impossible action on
approval of the new memorandum
of agreement between the Clark
County School District and the
Clark County Association of
School Administrators and
Professional Technical
Employees regarding 11 month
school principals. Trustees,
before we take any action on
this motion, can you guys go,
can you guys go back and take a
motion to accept the MOA on the
previous one? All you guys did
was close the public hearing.
So, that MOA is just sitting in
limbo right now. We don't want
that. Yeah. Thank you, Council.
Excellent. Just excuse me,
Doctor Dara, I saw that you
were in the queue. Is that the
same? Yup. Okie dokie pokey.
Here we go. Let's Trustee
Williams, I see that you are
ready to make a motion. I'll
fix it. Thank you, madam
president. At this time, I'd
like to make a motion to
approve five point zero 3. The
agreement between the Clark
County School District and the
Clark County Association of
School Administrators.
Excellent. Thank you very much.
We have Trustee Guzman
I'll second. again. Thank you
so much. We have a motion by
Trustee Williams. A second by
Trustee Guzman. Trustees please
cast your votes. And Trustee
Brooks. Aye. Thank you
Trustees. That motion passes.
Six to zero. Uh to approve the
MOA. Uh item five point oh
three. Thank you very much.
Okay. Now we will return back
to 5. 04. Thank you Mister Hall
believe we have to. Doctor
Jarro, thank you, thank you.
Let's see. Where are we, Doctor
Jara? Here we go. Madam Vice
President, members of the
board, I just I I can just
wanted to make a comment on on
the public hearing if you will
on five point 04. Uh I really
like to I know that the
executive director for Kasapi
is here, mister Horn. I've been
really coming to an agreement
on this. Um move forward as a
district. Um our principals in
all our schools the job has
become 12-month job. Uh and
with our staffing and and the
efforts to staff our schools
get ready not close out all the
summer work. Um this is a long
time coming in a in a the right
move for our building leaders
moving forward. So just really
appreciate the collaboration
and moving forward for our
students and our schools and
staff as well. Thank you. Thank
you Doctor Jarram. for sharing
those sentiments. I don't see
any public comment on a
5point04. So at this time we
must close. No, we don't have
to. Oh, okay. Well, let's just
close it. Call it a day, and
move on to a motion, the motion
part, the motion commotion. Uh
is there are there any
questions from trustees? I see
there's a couple trustees in
the queue who are ready just to
nope. No. Okay. That's we're
ready. Let's do it. Trustee
Guzman. Thank you. I'd like to
make a motion to accept the
memorandum of agreement to make
our principles from 11 month to
12 month. Is that correct? Next
I see Trustee Williams is ready
to make a motion too. Can can I
make a friendly amendment to
approve, approve, not accept,
is it accept? Cuz the thing
says approval and I don't
want to get galloped by our
attorney again. Sounds like it
is. Okay, it's got the
approved. Approved, approve.
Excellent. Trustees, we have a
motion by Trustee Williams and
a second, excuse me, a motion
by Trustee Guzman and second by
Trustee Williams. Please cast
your vote. Trustee Brooks.
Thank you, Trustee Brooks. That
motion passes, six to zero,
noting President Sepeda is not
present today. Thank you,
mister Hall for your time.
Thank you, Trustees. I'd like
to thank our administrators.
Thank you who work diligently
to support our students and
families. Thank you. For your
service to our district. At
this time, we'd like to move on
to at this time, we will move
on to 6. 01 public comment on
non agenda items. We are refer
to our sheet here. Uh who
individuals who have registered
beforehand. We have Jessica
Allen. Jessica, still here with
us. Alright, we are ready to
move on to yellow cards. Mellow
yellow. Let's see. We have miss
excuse me Sarah Esser. Sarah
present. Does it look like
Sarah? Is Ashanti Marshall?
and a binder Camilla Bywaters
Winner, winner, winner. Come on
down. I'd like to remind the
audience if there are
additional individuals who
would like to come up for
Putnam agenda items, please
complete a yellow card and we
will call you right up. Welcome
back, miss Bywaters. Oh, okay.
Oh, no. Forgive me. Welcome
back. Like. Oh. Thank you for
coming back. I thought you said
I'll come back. I was like, no,
no, no. You are, you are good
to go. Okay. Camilla Bywaters,
president of the Las Vegas
Alliance of Black School
Educators. Allow me to correct
the record. Um I can name
McCurdy McCurdy, Portsford. Um
I was referring to pressure by
CCSD to pay large sums of money
in a short amount of time. But
I am going to move on to a
second correction. We've been
told by our leaders. That our
HR report in regards to black
African American leadership has
increased by 30%. And that's
actually not accurate. I
researched and found the new HR
report. And we moved from a
whopping one hundred andforty
black African American
administrative staff, leader to
a whopping one hundred and
forty-eight over about a
five-year span. So, it seems
like we still have some work to
do. I do want to say
congratulations and thank you
for the urban, the pathway to
urban leadership. However, one
concern that I would have is
that that there's a specific
target to increase our black
leadership in that space. Um I
think just kind of leaving it
open. Um there can be some
missed opportunities to really
work on that equity issue there
and another point that I would
like to bring up about the
pathway to leadership, the
leadership plan. How does that
incorporate individuals who are
already have already gone
through the endorsement process
and are already prepared to be
principals in schools. So, it
really just addresses new
individuals who have not had a
chance to get a masters in
leadership. So, I want to just
ensure that appreciate the work
but that we really make sure
that we're not leaving out
people who still been in a
pipeline and have not had
opportunity to be promoted.
Thank you. Are there any other
individuals who'd like to
provide public comment? I do
not have cards. At this time,
I've been looking for a motion
from my colleagues and I am out
of time. Let's see. It's okay.
Thank you. Thank you, Trustee.
Guzman, I appreciate your
support. During today's
meeting. Trustee Williams.
Thank you, madam vice
president. This time, I'd like
to make a motion to adjourn
this meeting. Thank you,
Trustee Williams. Trustee
Guzman. I second. Trustees,
please cast your vote. Trustee
Brooks. Hi. That motion passes
six to zero. Noting. Oh, you
guys need to announce when the
next meeting was? Wow. Before
we accept that, ooh. Thank you.
Thank you. I wasn't following
my notes here and I'm so
grateful for the check.
Alright, ladies and gentlemen.
Ladies and gentlemen, upcoming
meetings, a Board of Trustees
is Monday, May 16th. That is a
budget meeting. It's at 5: 30
PM. Special meeting 530 PM. The
next meeting of the Board of
Trustees is on. May 19th on
Thursday, May 19th at five
o'clock. Right. At this time,
we will accept the motion that
our Trustee colleagues mate,
six to zero, not in Trustees is
dearly missed. Grateful. Thank
you for your time everybody.
Wishing you a good evening.